you need a
yes
you're the
best
members take your
seats
[Music]
I don't
know sign
you
I I think that we need to try someone
like ra their hand is there anything to
take off and be like I want to take off
this and have people
stand because I'm worried that we're
going to get in this
pattern have sign up ahead
of you know how you know if you want to
speak and they're like oh you didn't
sign up four days in a head
sure
This Day January 3rd 2024 the first
Wednesday following the first Tuesday in
January being a day designated by the
Constitution part two article 3 for
assembling of the second year session of
the 68 General Court the state of New
Hampshire the capital and the City of
conquer the 2024 House of leg
Representatives is now convened the
house will attend to a Prayer by house
chaplain Reverend Bob Stewart Pastor St
Paul's United Methodist Church in
Manchester good morning and happy New
Year since we last gathered we have lost
yet another member of the New Hampshire
House of
Representatives before we pray for
today's business
session let us pause for a few moments
of
silence as we reflect and remember our
friend and colleague representative Hoy
Robert maner III from Lee New
Hampshire
oh Living
God you share all our
griefs grant each gathered here today A
sense of your love and
peace as They Mourn the passing of their
friend and
colleague Reveal Your nearness to those
that suffer this
day surround them with the love that you
have for each of your
children we know that Hoy is held in
your loving arms and is at
peace and for that we give you our
thanks and
praise good morning God we begin the
2024 New Year together in this New
Hampshire House of
Representatives help us to be ever
mindful ful that with each new day of
this new year it is a day and year of
new
beginnings we start fresh we start a
new may it be a fruitful year where we
accomplish the business that is
important to the people we
represent give us Direction and wisdom
in this new
year be with each of of us as we discern
the legislation presented this day and
that we address the legislation to the
best of our
abilities we pray for your help so that
we can serve you and our constituents
with
Integrity we always seek your guiding
and protecting hand oh
God oh God of love and peace
it is my prayer that you would bless
each member of this house and that you
would bless all those that are in
positions of
leadership together we can make this a
year of
fruitfulness I pray for your peace to
come to this house this day and every
day of the new year
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
Windham representative Kathleen katab
who will lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance I to the of the United States
of America and to the for it stands one
nation God indivisible withy and justice
for
all the chair recognizes Brooke Martin a
sophomore from wiam who will sing our NA
national
anthem oh say can you
see by the early light what so
proud We H at the
Twilight last gleaming who's brought
stripes and bright
stars through the
perous fight or the r parts we watched
were so
gallantly
streaming and the
rocket the bones
bursting in air prove through the night
that that our flag was still
there do that
starled yet
wave or the
land of
thee in the home
of the
[Applause]
brave
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Ellison Gibbons Heath
Howard Lane lren peternell Ryan trevan
the day important business
Representatives con sandborn and
vanney these leaves of absent shall be
granted unless otherwise ordered by the
house the house will attend to the
introduction of guests house will be in
order Mr Speaker please welcome BJ and
Tony Martin family of the singer guests
of Representative cutab Roberta brona
guest of Representative Ellen Reed
Anthony Henry guest of Representative
Sweeney they are with us in the gallery
today Welcome to the New Hampshire
house
[Applause]
the house will be attentive while we
call the role of the house
electronically please press your green
button the chair asks that all members
please remain in their seats until a
quorum is declared present
the all right go ahead and open the vote
Mr Speaker members will please take
their seats members will take their
seats
[Music]
like
for
got
[Music]
El
e
good
363 with 363 members having answered the
call the chair declares a quorum present
the house will attend a m Morrow
resolution
Mr Speaker house resolution
32 whereas we have learned with profound
sorrow of the passing of our colleague
and friend Hoy Robert maner III who was
serving his second term as a state
representative representing the towns of
Lee and Madbury and Ward four in the
city of Dover and whereas having
formerly served on the committee on Ways
and Means Hoy AR manir was serving on
the committee on state federal relations
and Veterans Affairs and whereas having
had a successful career as an investment
Banker Hoy AR maner utilized his
analytical skills by plunging into his
legislative work and whereas a man of
many talents Hoy R maner was
passionately well read and as such was
gifted in the art of rhetoric now be it
therefore resolved by the House of
Representatives and regular session
convened Hoy arm manir III be granted
our highest praise and accolades and
offered our profound thanks for his
service to his home community in the
state of New
Hampshire please rise and join me in a
moment of silence for our representative
from Lee The Honorable Hoy
minir thank you Mr
speaker thank you for the uh moment of
silence and Remembrance for uh Roger
manir was what he went by that's what we
knew him as
Roger Roger and I met in 2012 as
candidates for House Seats serving
barington and Lee uh we each served one
term and moved on to other things in
2014 Roger returned to the house this
term to represent Lee Madbury and do
Ward 4 he was a semi-retired investment
banker with an MBA from the University
of Michigan and a master's degree from
unh
it was our Midwestern roots and a run
for the State House in 2012 that created
a bond we shared for the last
decade he believed in
education good wages for public
employees protecting the environment and
Health Care access for women through his
work in personal exercise fitness
program Roger made many friends here he
took exceptional care of his health and
looked and acted great for a person of
any age he was in his mid 80s
he was a rower and coached many young
men in the sport and his favorite book
which he demanded that I read was the
boys in the boat which is about to be
released in theaters it's uh he would he
would have liked that Roger was direct
his honesty integrity and diligence were
extraordinary over the last 10 years we
spoke frequently and organized a summer
cookout with his many friends that he
made here in New Hampshire it was
important for him to stay in touch with
those in his life who meant the most to
him and he never asked for anything in
return except for a good bottle of pin
Noir and a red velvet cake that my wife
used to make for a dessert for
that there are many friends that we keep
for our entire
life then there are the newer friends
who help us realize how fortunate we are
and for what we are thankful for while
I've met many people myself and my 20
years here in New Hampshire Roger was
the one person who I regularly spoke
with and it was usually on our way to
our respective health
clubs uh for a
workout we saved time for longer
conversations during his drives back and
forth to Ohio to meet his with his
clients and his friends from his home
state and his Alma moer the University
of
Michigan sometimes Roger would make that
drive just to attend a performance of
the Cleveland
Orchestra if he were here now I know
he'd be making plans to drive to the
national champion ionship college
football game to watch the University of
Michigan in fact this year's team was
the dominant topic of our last
conversation over the years I realized
what a special and kind person he really
was and how much he cared about those
who were least able to help themselves
and the import the importance of arts
and
education of course our conversations
were peppered with our individual takes
on Politics as well Roger subscribed to
many national newspapers and periodicals
and he would send me articles that he
thought I would find
interesting he included the editorial
cartoons from those same Publications to
make sure we kept our sense of humor and
a positive outlook and a healthy
skepticism I miss
him he had a full and rewarding life
with friends and clients who were
corresponding and talking with him until
he
passed while Roger may have grown up in
Ohio he was every bit of New Englander
he could squeeze a dime out of a
nickel he was Frugal yet generous
personnic but
engaging educated and
funny and he was one of the best friends
one could ever have thank
[Applause]
you
the house will attend to
Communications
speaker for reason to member rise move
to place the remarks in the permanent
journal without
objection Mr Speaker in the Comm
communication dated November 29th 2023
dear Paul please be advised that the
following representative elect was sworn
into office by the governor and
executive Council this day Hillsboro
County District 3 pae Bosman sincerely
David M scanland Secretary of
State congratulations and welcome to the
New Hampshire
[Applause]
house
okay further
Communications Mr Speaker in a
communication dated November 29 2023
dear speaker Packard please accept this
letter as my formal resignation from the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
effective Friday December 1st 2023 I'll
be moving out of my district of
Rockingham 21 it has been a privilege to
serve the people of portsman Swords 1 in
Newington for this term and
representative of my community within
the halls of our great state capital has
been one of the greatest honors of my
life I send my gratitude and respect to
all my colleague colleagues in the New
Hampshire House of Representatives as
they continue to work towards improving
the granted state for many years to come
respectfully submitted Robin vote uh
Rockingham district
21 with regret we accept the
resignation the house will attend to a
resolution Mr Speaker representative
Osborne offers the following resolve
that in accordance with the list in the
possession of the clerk house bills
numbered 1,000 through 1372 1374 through
1377 1379 through 1440 1442 through 1710
and 2024 house concurrent resolutions
numbered 8- 11 house resolutions
numbered 19-31 and Constitutional
Amendment concurrent resolutions
numbered 11- 21 23 25 and 26 shall be by
this resolution read a first and second
time by the therein listed titles and
referred to the their and designated
committees are you ready for the
question all those faor say I those
oppos nay the eyes have it resolution is
adopted the house will now attend to the
consent
calendar Mr Speaker from the committee
on children and family law House Bill
499 removed by Representatives Hull
Belcher Prout Hines Granger Spain Penza
Bernardi mcarter and soroy from the
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety House Bill 144 removed by reps
ghard green rer marter kulan Santa aaso
wheeler alisandra Murray Phillips Ellen
Reed yella and Terry from the committee
on criminal justice and public safe
safety House Bill 512 removed by reps
Gard Granger mcarter kulan santonastaso
wheeler alisandra Murray Phillips Ellen
Reed yella and Terry from the committee
on executive departments and
administration House Bill 518 removed by
Representatives grota Carol Maguire Tony
leus Julie Smith Mana py Fred Davis
marer Smith Lynn grassy and Schmidt from
the committee on Municipal and County
government House Bill 526 removed by
Representatives Wilhelm Simpson walner
tersi Sullivan stavis eel Weber Shapiro
and
maor are there any other bills to be
removed representative Osborne moves a
consent calendar with a relevant
amendments as printed in the days house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those opposed n the eyes have it consent
calendar is adopted sentive set declared
a conflict of interest on House Bill 571
sen sidec declared a conflict of
interest in House Bill 318 they did not
participate in the vote on the consent
calendar under the rules of the house
from the committee on Commerce and
consumer affairs House Bill 279 is
referred to the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety from the
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety House Bill 318 and Senate Bill
252 referred to the committee on
finance the house will now attend to the
bills on the regular
calendar majority of the committee on
children and family law to which was
referred House Bill 185 FN act relative
to deter determination of parental
rights and responsibilities based on
shared parenting and shared access to
the child's records considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment sen Lori
ball from majority of the
committee minority of the
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
Senator Patrick long from the minority
of the
committee
the amendment is
H printed in house record 49 Pages 56-
57 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I those
oppos nay eyes have it an amendment is
adopted we're now on to autop pass with
Amendment and the chair
recognizes
chair recognizes representative
Greg thank you Mr Speaker it's been a
hot minute I didn't hear my name I don't
it does goes kind of without saying but
relationships are complicated even the
good ones have some complications and
children and with children those
complications grow exponentially now
throw in a separation of parents do due
to an inability to cohabitate for
various reasons in those complications
Skyrocket there is no simple one size
fits all fixed to make everyone happy
however with current statutes and
judicial procedures just over 90% of
cases agree on what is best for their
child without the need for further Court
action to decide the remaining
9% those are our small number of high
conflict cases
high conflict where there have been
major breakdowns between parents there
could be substance abuse major monetary
disagreements mental health
complications among other things this is
also where we see domestic violence
claims in that layer of substantiated
claims we have those that lack the
insight to understand that their
behaviors are abusive and not just a
matter of course in a
relationship so what we are looking at
with hb1 85 is a bill that is looking to
make that quick fix for a small
percentage not put the needs of families
and Children First particularly in
situations where there is abuse and
parents who are incapable of providing
for their children's needs or where
parents don't live in close
proximity claims about bills like this
lowering cases of domestic violence just
don't hold water while in 2019 one of
the few states that has a shared parent
parenting law had some statistics
claiming that the Shared Parenting Bill
greatly solved the problem their first
ever Statewide data from 22 that was
just released in 23 shows a market
increase in domestic violence as
legislators looking at bills like this
is a precarious situation there must be
a balance of
power we can't just continue to change
wording in hopes of
forcing judges into a one size fits none
approach when they should be looking at
each very unique case to decide what is
best in the best interest for families
on that same note we can't give judges
who don't want to bother with the
complexities of these cases an easy and
potentially damaging easy out the
language of our current bill frequent
and continuing contact is not a problem
with the language it's a problem with
the application of that language that
application is is a part of judicial
training it is not something we solve
with this bill please vote for the best
interest of families and vote no to HB
185 chair recognize representative
ball thank you Mr Speaker and I ask for
a division
vote New Hampshire RSA makes it clear
that because people I'm sorry makes it
clear and I quote because children do
best when both parents have a stable and
meaningful involvement in their lives it
is a state policy of this state unless
shown that a particular case is
detrimental in a particular case it is
detrimental to the child to support
frequent and continued contact with each
child and both parents the words of RSA
461 have led most parents seeking a
divorce to enter Family Court believing
that New Hampshire is a 5050 state in
fact many attorneys in our state advise
their clients not to ask for more than
50% parenting time because it is
understood that frequent and continuing
contact means approximately equal
parenting
time even some of the members of the
children and family law committee
interpreted the words frequent and
continuing contact to mean approximately
equal that is until the special
committee to investigate Family Court
went to visit courtrooms around the
state and interviewed many judges and
what the special committee found shocked
us while the majority of Family Court
judges interpreted frequent and
continuing contact to mean a starting
point of 5050 and then moving away from
that based on Parental input and other
extenuating circumstances we were
shocked to find three three judges did
not approach parenting plans with a
starting point of 50/50 they believe
parenting PL should start at zero and
then work upward in other words whoever
is a primary bread winner whether it be
the mother or the father could be
relegated to being a visitor in their
child's life seeing their child every
other weekend and maybe a Wednesday
night for dinner solely because that
parent spent less time with the children
prior to deliver divorce due to work
obligations outside of the home clearly
it is neither Fair nor Equitable to the
children who by our own State policy do
best when both parents have a stable and
meaningful involvement in their lives
recent State and National studies show
that failing to provide children with
opportunities for a stable and
meaningful relationship with both
parents have serious detrimental effects
on the children according to researchers
the absence of a father in a child's
life is nothing more nothing short of
disastrous 71% of high school dropouts
are fatherless children and 90% of
runaway children have an absent
father knowing these statistics how can
we allow Family Court to lack
consistency in the approach to the
parenting plans how can we as
legislators allow families to walk into
court with similar circumstances and
walk out with different outcomes based
upon which courtroom they walked into
and which judge they were
assigned New Hampshire is better than
that we are better than that the
evidence is clear for the past several
years over 20 New Hampshire judges have
been helping parents create parenting
plans that provide each parent
approximately equal parenting time time
whether that be 5050 or 6040 and we have
seen no increases of neglect or abuse in
those
families it is time to get all of our
family court judges on the same page and
interpret the law as it was
intended it is time to take the
vagueness out of RSA 461 and make it
clear New Hampshire children do best
when both parents have a stable in their
lives it is time
to make it clear that meaningful
involvement means approximately equal
parenting time with each child and both
parents this amendment changes only four
words in RSA
461 it in no way diminishes the
authority of the judge to use his
discretion in cases where approximately
equal parenting time would be
detrimental to the child this Amendment
continues to provide the exact same
protection for victims of domestic
violence abuse and
neglect and this amendment does not
prevent parents from creating parenting
plans that work for them four simple
words four words that create a fair and
Equitable starting point for the vast
majority of good loving parents who
agree they can no longer live together
but want what's in the best interest of
their child four words that would assure
all judges interpret the law in the same
manner four words that would make it
clear that New Hampshire children do
best when both parents have a stable and
meaningful involvement in their lives by
supporting approximately equal parenting
time between each child and both parents
please press the green button and make
it the policy of our great state of New
Hampshire that children children do best
when they have approximately equal
parenting time with both parents thank
you did you request a roll call he
doesn't
representative Pelos off is requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded yeah it's sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
know
the question before the house is the
report about to pass as amended on House
Bill 185 this is a roll call
vote representative long is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that New Hampshire
coalition ition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence in the state's 12 crisis
centers oppose this bill because it
would endanger victims of domestic
violence and their children and if I
further know that there is no one size
fits-all for every family in New
Hampshire and if I know that house bill
185 will force families into parenting
plans that do not meet their unique
needs and finally if I know that the
majority of child custody and parenting
time in New Hampshire already exist in
equal parenting and if I know that
judges should continue to have
discretion when considering the best
interest of the child would I push the
rest the red button thank
you well
then representative Maori is recognized
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that more than 40 Years of
social science research establishes a
growing consensus that in the vast
majority of cases children raised and
shared parenting Arrangements score
significantly higher on almost every
metric of child well-being than those
raised in Soul custody arrangements and
Mr Speaker if I further know that re
research shows that benefits to Children
arise because both parents are
significantly involved in ordinary
day-to-day parenting responsibilities
and the benefits of shared parenting for
children increases as the time with each
parent approaches
equality and Mr Speaker if I know that
there is no empirical evidence to
support shared parenting leaves children
vulnerable to to abuse then Mr Speaker
would I go ahead and press the green
button to support House Bill 185 thank
you this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor press the green button if
you're opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
check in yes
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 202 in the affirmative 172 and the
negative the motion is
adopted
the clerk told me I could go home for
the
day okay committee on children and
family law to which was referred House
Bill
475 an act establishing a right to
submit evidence and testimony and family
court proceedings considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation that the bill
out to pass with Amendment Senator Mark
Pearson for the committee the amendment
is
2324 printed in house record 49 page
79 motion before is on the amendment all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
those of the eyes have it the amendment
is adopted the motion before us now now
is ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the out report is
adopted committee on children and family
law to which was referred House Bill
3535 FN act requiring an attorney for a
child who is the subject of a proceeding
in a family court case consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation the bill
ought to pass with Amendment Patrick
long for the committee the amendment is
23568 printed in house record 49 Pages
885 and 86 the question before you was
on the amendment all those in favor say
I I those n the eyes have it amendment
is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the report is adopted
committee on carers and consumer affairs
to which was referred House Bill 225 FN
act relative to prohibiting the use of
currency that could be detrimental to
privacy rights considered the same
report the same with the following
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study sen of Keith Ammon for
the
committee chair recognizes
representative
Herbert he said he's on the next one
this one I need to just signed you up
for this one that's why there
the
the motion before us is refer ref for
inum study on House Bill 225 FN are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted oneone
de majority of the committee on consume
Commerce and consumer affairs to which
was referred House Bill 227 an act
relative to Fair access to financial
services consider the same report the
same with the recommendation the bill be
referred for interim study Su pelli for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate jerob
Sullivan from the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative
Sullivan thank you Mr Speaker so this
bill on its face sounds is like actually
a decent idea the idea of this bill it's
under what is the title relative to Fair
access of financial services that
suggests that there's some sort of
problem with discrimination going on and
perhaps there's a a reason for us to
step in when you dig a Little Deeper
this is definitely a a wolf and sheep's
clothing type bill because what we see
happening is the protected classes that
we all I think would be concerned about
being discriminated against race gender
religion they're all protected under
numerous banking laws that are already
on the books things like the Civil
Rights Act the Equal Credit Opportunity
Act Community reinvestment act there's
tons of these those are just a few that
I just named that cover all the
protected classes I think the vast
majority of us in society are concerned
about being discriminated against what
this does the motivation behind this
bill is to try to and and for me the
most offensive part of it is it's it's
an egregious attack on the free market
and an attempt to
push kind of uneven substantiated
concerns into the the way we give out
loans so for example the motivation
behind this is to prevent Banks from
considering things that are not
traditional Financial metrics now who's
going to Define what traditional
Financial metrics are do we think that
traditional Financial metrics have been
static throughout time of course not
there are different Financial metrics
that are considered today than they were
considered in 1900 and no doubt there'll
be different ones traditional Financial
metrics that will be considered in
201100 so it it tramps on the idea that
the free Market is is somehow
ineffective at deciding what business
should or should not get loans so the
concern here was that some banks might
make loans based on things like ESG
which are the sustainability type things
and to my response is hey I don't I
don't really have a a say on whether or
not a bank should or should not make
loans based on other goals that they may
have all banks presumably are in the
business of making money if they're
going to consider these things it's part
of their Innovative strategy or what
they think to be a successful strategy
in winning business and making money
with their Investments who are we as
legislators who don't fully understand
the banking industry and the needs of
the banking industry to tell them what
they can and cannot consider it would
kill innovation in the banking sector it
would also hurt innovation in the
private sector because it's finance that
helps Drive Innovation by providing the
money that they need to get new
businesses going the idea that the free
Market can't handle this problem if it
indeed is a problem is kind of on its
face a bit ging to me so if there is a
concern that there is collusion going on
say all the banks are getting together
and saying we're not going to give loans
to an oil company or some other company
that is offensive under the ESG
framework that's already illegal that we
go to the Department of Justice we go to
the Attorney General's office point it
out and sue them the these things this
is a a solution to a problem that does
not not exist it was not proven to the
committee and I really hope that you
guys can join me vote down the interim
study which suggests that there's a
problem that's worth studying when in
fact there is not if you believe in the
free market and you are concerned of the
idea of growing our Nanny State and
growing the size of our government
please vote no against the interim study
for this so we can make a better motion
thank
you J recogize representative
hunt
thank you Mr
Speaker uh Mr Speaker some of you might
have attended the study committee uh
continuing education and in which uh at
that session I educated you all on what
Commerce does and commerce has broken up
into several different
divisions and we uh tried not to pass
legislation that is uh not ready for
prime time and instead we keep the bill
we like to keep it in the committee so
that if there's another headline another
issue that uh people say well why aren't
you doing something about this or what
how can this happen at least we have a
standing uh subcommittee that will
review the issue and we have a
legislation that we can use as a title
to call that hearing that is the only
reason we are retaining this bill or
interim study excuse me retained it and
then didn't do anything with it we're
interim studying it now so all I can to
ask you is please support the interim
study please do not fear that the
Commerce Committee is going to be out to
uh change the way we do banking in the
state as a matter of fact we have
another bill just coming next up is
going to radically change and make
things really great for the Hampshire so
I'm asking you please at this time just
vote Yes on interim study thank
you a roll call has been requested and
it is sufficiently
seconded representative Reed requested
the roll call and is sufficiently
seconded members take your seats this
will be a roll call
vote
[Music]
clear
the motion before us is the committee
the majority committee report or
referred for interim
study this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative bolo for a
parliamentary
inquiry if I believe this underlying
bill would simply grow the size of our
government and increase the regulatory
burden for the New Hampshire banking
industry and if I believe growing the
size of government without any clear
benefit helps nobody then will I vote no
and join me and vote no and stop the
creation of a study committee because
the underlying Bill isn't worth being
studied thank
you you recognize your represent of hunt
for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
support the what commerce's committee is
doing in terms of taking bills and just
holding on to them so that when an issue
does pop up in the headlines of the
newspaper they have something to work
with will I now vote Yes on the pending
motion the motion before us is the
majority committee report of refer for
inm study this is a roll call vote if
you are in favor you'll press the green
button if your oppos you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
Perez yes or no thank
you while members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the
vote 182 voting nay 193 voting nay the
motion
[Music]
fails representative Sullivan moves in
expedient to
legislate are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes have
it 93 to 18
82 majority of the committee on Commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred House Bill 645 FN act relative
the establishment of decentralized non
autonomous organizations as legal
entities within the state considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation the
bill ought to pass with Amendment
Senator Keith Ammon for the majority of
the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with a majority a report with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate sen Christoper
Heber for the minority of the
committee okay the amendment is
23278 printed in house record 49 9 Pages
96 through 106 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppos n the eyes
have it the amendment is adopted the
motion before us now is ought to pass
with
Amendment chair recognizes
representative
Heber um I've been up here before and so
I think you already know that I'm
opposed to cryptocurrency as its entity
uh in this particular case um the the
idea is to install or pass legislation
to
regulate what uh inevitably will be
cryptocurrency and as a result of that
we made a decision for the entire state
that
cryptocurrency is going to be uh
allowed embraced
and I know for a fact that most people
have no idea what that
means and so as a result I uh I'm here
to point out just a few characteristics
of
crypto
um this is one of many parts of a
concerted effort to create a crypto
ecology in New
Hampshire the
legislature the legislature has not been
sufficiently educated on what the E this
ecology is the crypto environment
nationally has caused many negative
externalities and uh and I'm I'm
referring to
fraud uh in
particular including fraud and literally
billions of dollars in losses to
shareholders many informed and famous
investors consider this system to be
unstable among them are Charles M the
late Charles
merer um Warren
Buffett of Berkshire hathway both of
those are Berkshire hathway and Jamie
Diamond CEO of JP Morgan Chase Munger
said cryptos will eventually become
worthless while Buffett considers crypto
to be nothing more than a gambling token
other words it has transactional value
but not intrinsic value there is no
intrinsic uh property yet that is uh
recognized as it would be if it was a
legitimate
currency excuse
me okay thank
you uh Diamond uh said uh buying crypto
is like buying a pet
rock the majority believe crypto's
Providence
is is a money laundering tool for
internet AAL illegal
cabals and considers uh and and
um tax
cheats the majority believes okay among
the responsibilities of the Commerce
Committee is to protect citizens to
protect citizens from Consumer Fraud and
the like crypto's Providence and
difficulties clearly show that this
system should not be endorsed in any
shape
perform and as a former marilin broker I
can tell you unequivocally that the
cryptocurrency is considered far far out
on the risk curve in other words I would
as a broker I would have never
recommended a customer invest any money
in in such a risky risky piece of paper
and
finally it's Commerce and consumer
affairs so in other words not only do we
deal with insurance and and Banking and
and those uh kinds of subjects but it is
Our
obligation to um
protect our
constituents from taking a major risk
that they may not understand exact exact
exists now you can go to a casino and
make a
killing right but if everybody did it
there would be no
casinos so the fact of the matter
is U and finally the last thing I'll say
is that the uh legitimate
currencies uh also trade but they have
uh more than transactional value but
um cryptocurrency and I don't know if
you've followed the gyration and the
price of this this outfit but uh is 10
times 10 times as volatile as legitimate
currencies so with all those
difficulties I think it's my obligation
to uh not vote to
endorse uh such a volatile risky
investment uh and so as a result of that
I would hope to uh that you would see it
my way and uh avoid the chance that some
of your constituents are going to lose a
lot of money when the uh scheme
collapses thank
you should I do a I like a a vote and do
I want to take a uh not a roll call vote
but uh just an up and down
vote huh yeah division vote you want a
division yes sir
okay all right you want a division okay
chair recognize representative
hun all right thank you Mr Speaker so Mr
Speaker I'm really proud to say that
this is a something the study committees
have been working very hard on in
Commerce and puts this out on the
Forefront of not
cryptocurrency it is blockchain but this
is something a little bit different this
is corporate
structure so you all remember LL LC's
right well before llc's there was sub
chapter S in this case what we're doing
today is going to
revolutionalize way someone can create a
business a corporation and instead of
having u a board of directors and have a
uh firm structure that most corporations
have now we're going to use the
cryptocurrency excuse me blockchain
concept to build a company around that
organiz ations of all those members
working together it's open system so
anybody can see exactly how they're
doing it it's uh monitored uh by
actually the Secretary of State uh as
which does all our corporations now will
be able to uh monitor it and recognize
what it's doing Dr is uh very excited
about it because they see all kinds of
new opportunities to bring in new
revenues because people are going to
want to come here to come to New
Hampshire to create one of these why
would they want to come here well
because these things are already
happening already now across the country
these Dows but they are
unregulated the idea that you could
create one that was regulated by a state
that had governance it had guard rails
this is the most exciting thing we have
done in Commerce in the last couple
years since since we passed the trust
law so I'm very happy to say that that I
think everyone wants to be in support of
this bill so thank you and and let's be
very proud that we got this accomplished
thank you does the member yield a
questions sir member
yields thank you for taking my question
so just wanted to clarify one thing
given we've heard does this bill
actually have anything whatsoever to do
with cryptocurrency and the concerns
about cryptocurrency it has nothing to
do with cryptocurrency except that it's
it's using the same structure the
blockchain concept that's the only thing
it has comparison to crypto thank
you do a member yield to further
questions member
yields thank you I wouldn't exactly call
Dr excited except that uh they're going
to have to learn a totally new frame of
government of business but uh and this
also is true for the Secretary of State
are you growing
government so yes absolutely both the ra
and the secretary of state which does
corporate division everyone is involved
everyone has been support of this bill
as
written the motion before us is the
majority committee report of lot of pass
as amended on House Bill 645 this is
going to be a division vote members take
your seats
[Music]
sorry
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of aut pass in 645 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative Julie
Smith representative Julie
Smith yes or no thank
you represent
jur
representative
Mirad represent angerberg
wsh
all members present and opportunity to
vote household tend the state of the
vote 340 voting a 33 voting a committee
report is
adopted
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which is referred House Bill
113 relative to the physical fitness
performance requirements for law
enforcement officers this is comes
without
recommendation the chair recognizes
representative rhs for what reason
member rise thank you Mr Speaker I Rise
to make a motion Motion state your
motion I make a motion to table House
Bill
113 that is a proper motion the motion
before us is to the table House Bill
113 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I those oppose
[Music]
nay Vision Vision has been
requested members in the room
only close the door
all
right the motion before us is to lay on
the table H Bill
113 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
for
representative
Woodcock representative
bone representative
cascat represent Sy
represent
B
finny representative lad and
cordelli
[Music]
represent
Dolan represent
love
right all members present have an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state to the
vote
159 voting aay 212 voting a the motion
to table
fails representative Manion moves ought
to
pass and chair recognizes representative
wheeler thank you Mr
Speaker I rise today against the ought
to pass motion for this legislation this
bill we got last year in the committee
and was retained for a study committee
that was chaired by my friend from
chesher and my friend from chesher went
through very diligently with police
standards and training and director
Skipper going over this bill going over
line by line how best we could approach
train changing the training standards
for our police officers cuz we recognize
that the int intent of the sponsor of
this bill is well put there is a serious
issue with retainment a serious issue
with recruitment but I believe that
solving that issue is not done by
lowering the standards we can solve that
issue by actually paying our police
officers a decent wage and giving them
livable working conditions so I think if
you're a police officer who's trying to
catch a per if you're a police officer
who's going into a school or a or trying
to address something going on in the
community I think if you have backup
you'd like that backup to be able to run
with you to be able to keep up to be
able to stay fit and active we have
Fitness requirements mental requirements
for Pilots we wouldn't want our pilot
not to be physically or mentally fit we
have requirements yearly for teachers
they have to do workshops we wouldn't
want our teachers not to be able to do
their jobs we have requirements for
train Engineers we wouldn't want them to
be able to do a TR to run the train
which is itself on a track so why would
we not have requirements for police
officers who do the job of protecting
our community and if we go back to our
communities and say hey guys we just
lower the standards for cops anyone can
become a cop you don't have to take the
test then I think we would be we would
be failing them you know we we police
officers should be fit they should be
active and they that's how we can
protect our communities here so if we
want to address the retention and the
pay issue which my friend
is totally correct we should address
that issue let's come together and try
to find some way to pay them more and
make their conditions better because
they do a terribly hard job that is a
terribly hard task and being fit
requires to do that job so thank you Mr
Speaker and I would ask that you vote
against the a toass motion so another
motion could be
made chair recognizes representative
Dennis
Manion
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I rise
in support of House Bill 113 I've been
in law enforcement for 30 years so I was
a part of law enforcement before this
law went to effect and after it went
into effect um it was my understanding
back then that it was put in place to
reduce workman's comp claims for
injuries however no evidence was
presented to us at all that was the case
I'll stop by saying this this bill does
not eliminate the police standards and
training council's physical fitness
training requirements for law
enforcement offices it does not
eliminate it what this bill does do it
repeals a law that was enacted 20 plus
years ago that also requires that the
law enforcement officer Contin
continuously pass this physical fitness
standard every three years during his or
her career what's the issue with that
you might ask first it hurts Recruitment
and Retention of experienced officers
contrary to what it might have been said
there are a lot of towns right now
offering sign on bonuses so 15 20
$30,000 and that's still not bringing
people in it's not about the
money in addition New Hampshire has
always been a place where officers who
retired from neighboring states would
come to work often as police Chiefs in
small
towns that is years of experience in
training we are potentially losing due
to this law because they don't want to
come to New Hampshire in their 40s and
50s and have to do these physical
fitness tests every three
years most of the uh people like
lieutenants captains and police Chiefs
uh they might be the kind of people who
go to the gym three to five days a week
but these are the kind of people who
retire as soon as they're able to
causing agencies to lose years of
experience or in the case of officers
who retired from another state they
would not choose New Hampshire at all
again years of experience and training
that we are losing keep in mind that
there are many different types of
assignments in law enforcement not all
of them require top physical fitness
standards if you're on a SWAT team per
se and uh they have their own strict
standards in order to be on that part of
that team you have to pass those so the
the people who need to be physically fit
are remaining physically
fit if you're a person who's
investigating fatal motor vehicle
accidents or crime scenes white Coller
crimes or computer crimes that expertise
is still
needed in a profession that is
struggling to fill positions we should
not be pushing out our most experienced
officers second New Hampshire is the
only state in the country that has this
law the only state and only for law
enforcement offices we don't require it
of our fighter fighters or our EMTs or
our teachers that I know of this is a
mandate imposed by the state however law
enforcement officers are not paid to
work out in preparation for the
three-year physical fitness not only are
they not paid but if they injured while
preparing for this test they are not
likely to be covered by workman's
comp
fourth the state uses a Cooper standard
and that testing is outdated I have
spoken to quite a few officers and
police Chiefs in and around my district
who feel that they this should be done
on a local level a lot of towns and
cities already have yearly incentive
based physical fitness requirements and
it rewards an officer who completes it
with a stipend the Chiefs I spoke with
would also like local control over their
own agency with the ability to create a
more realistic testing process and
finally the penalty fulfilling this
requirement is severe if you miss a mile
and a half run by a few seconds or a few
sit-ups or a few push-ups short you lose
your certification you lose your career
and you can't work in New Hampshire
anymore let's repeal the state mandate
and return local control to our towns
and cities who know best about what they
require of our local law enforcement
offic I ask you to vote Yes on
OTP does the member does the member
yield to
questions no member does not
yield the motion before us is to is aut
to pass on House Bill
113 are you ready for the
questionis the division has been
requested members take your
seats
e
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 113 this is a division
vote chair recognizes representative
Nancy Murray Murphy for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that Fitness
requirements in law enforcement such as
currently exis in New Hampshire are
consistent across the state are directly
related to the ability of Law
Enforcement Officers to perform the
essential functions of their jobs and
are important to help distinguish
between those who can and cannot meet
employment
expectations and if I know
the testimony provided to the committee
indicated that the New Hampshire Chiefs
of police could not attain consensus on
this bill and have chosen to remain
neutral on its
disposition and finally if I know that
repealing New Hampshire's physical
fitness requirements for law enforcement
officers rather than moving to a
different kind of test or Fitness
standard as John shippa director of New
Hampshire police standard and training
Council has stated he is open to
could lead to an increase in positive
negative outcomes then would I now press
the red button to vote no and allow New
Hampshire's police St standards and
training Council the appropriate body to
maintain the decision-making Authority
and discretion it has to determine
physical fitness standards for certified
New Hampshire Law Enforcement
Officers chair recognizes representative
Dennis Manion for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
find out that this bill does not
eliminate the standard uh training
physical fitness requirements to become
a certified police officer it only
repeals a law requiring officers to pass
this standard every 3 years after that
and if I know the law hurts Recruitment
and Retention of experienced offices in
a profession that is struggling to fill
positions and if I know that New
Hampshire is the only state in the
country that has this law and it only
applies to law enforcement officers and
if I know that officers not paid to work
out in preparation for this three-year
physical fitness test and if I know that
the penalty for failing this requirement
is losing your certification therefore
losing your career when I now press the
green button to repeal the state mandate
and return local control to our towns
and cities where it belongs thank
you motion before us is aut to pass on
House Bill 113 this is a division vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
e
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the
vote 178 voting aay 195 voting aay the
aut to pass motion
fails representative wheeler moves
inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay you guys have
it committee report any experience the
legisl is
adopted first up is the
am
the chair recognizes the clerk Mr
Speaker representative Osborne offers
the following resolve that in accordance
with the list in the possession of the
clerk House Bill 1711 shall be by this
resolution read a first and second time
by the their incit title and referred to
the committee on criminal justice and
Public
Safety all those in favor say I I those
oppose nay
the eyes have it the resolution
adopted majority committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which is
referred House Bill 47 efn in act
relative to fentanyl test strips and
Other Drug checking equipment considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment Senor David muse from majority
of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that as
inexpedient to legislate sen Jeffrey
tenar for the minority of the
committee the amendment 2
422h printed in house record 49 Pages 76
through 79 this is a question on the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the is adopted
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment sen H offers Amendment
41h it's in your seat
pocket thank you Mr
Speaker good morning Happy New
Year the amendments in your pocket it's
two lines long it's very short but since
it's removing something I want to point
you to the calendar where it is it's on
page 78 it removes
one
definition um and the definition is
relative to harm
reduction I don't sit on criminal
justice I sit on house finance we had a
lot of discussions in house finance
regarding harm reduction it's a term
that's not necessary for this bill to
proceed forward it's a term that was
included in a definition that doesn't
impact this legislation at all the
amendment simply removes that additional
definition that was incl uded in the
bill so that we can go ahead and deal
with the fentanyl test strips which is
the thing that we want to get passed I
would ask that you would adopt Amendment
0041 H thank
you chair recognize representative
Nel
thank you Mr Speaker sorry about that um
just wanted to speak also on the same
thing you already know what the
amendment is about um what did I learn
in the last year in this body um one of
the things that I did in my work for 35
years as advocating for the rights of
people in pain and seeking for um
balance between public policy between
those in pain and those who suffer from
addiction um is that the concept of harm
reduction is extremely important it's
extremely complicated I spent the last
um year talking to people on both sides
of this body both within and without
about this and what I learned was that
it's a complex subject that defies
simple
definition um
um I talked with the regional director
of samsa substance abuse mental health
Service Agency who's our regional
director as well as that of the Midwest
um she pointed out a definition that
they just released to me it is more than
10 pages long um the concern though then
is when you create Simplicity out of
complexity you lose the value of what
you're talking about and that's what
this definition does it's overly
simplistic and by definition it will
create the a potential for unintended
consequences that can be somewhat
problematic and that's why we asked that
it be removed from this bill and as the
representative mentioned um it does not
affect the Bill's content otherwise
thank
you chair recogniz your representative
Muse thank you Mr Speaker we spent uh a
considerable time in committee on HB 470
uh we spent a lot of time reviewing our
drug paraphernalia Law And while
additional changes are are something
that I think we can and should consider
uh at some point in the future um one of
the things that I'd be very much aware
of with uh with law like this um is the
danger of unintended
consequences so during testimony for HP
470 uh law enforcement made us aware of
things that we weren't aware of and
that's why we have testimony in the
first place um that's why we have these
hearings
um this particular change was not
suggested uh as part of that process we
don't have input from any of the
stakeholders on this and uh I would urge
you uh to put this one to bed thank
you the motion before us is floor whole
floor Amendment 0041 h a division has
been requested this will be a division
vote members take your seats
for
clear
the motion before us is the whole
Amendment
0041 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
e represent
ban represent
Mirad represent
Carri representative
MC
sir have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
say the
vote 178 voting a 194 voting a the whole
Amendment fails now
we the motion before us now is the
majority committee report of a to pass
as amended chair recognizes
representative
rhs thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker we're we're going to be told
that HB 570 will save
lives and the reality is that this bill
goes far beyond allowing the person to
have drug testing equipment this bill
has devastating unintended consequences
that aren't going to be
reversible in fact HB 470 will make it
legal for a person to possess 10
milligrams of an unknown controlled
substance for reference 2 mg of fentanyl
is considered to be a lethal
dose car fentanyl is 100 times more
potent than Fentanyl and this bill will
allow for
500 lethal doses of
it additionally carop fetanyl is so
toxic that a single grain of it on your
bare skin can ca to cause to an overdose
and
death if you ask an em T if 10
milligrams is considered to be a Teensy
weny amount they're going to tell you no
cuz I asked
them if you find 10 milligrams of what
we were told is what's left in the bag
after the drugs have already been
done chances are good you're going to be
concerned that you found 10 milligrams
of drugs in your child's
room the other thing is we were told
this is after the drugs are done so how
are you testing if you already the drug
this bill kicks the door open for abuse
police won't be able to investigate many
of the cases the person claims they are
engaged in harm reduction won't have to
prove that it will stop the police from
being able to enforce drug laws and does
not allow Pro probation or parole to be
enforced we already passed HB 287 that
was that was the mechanism for these
drugs to be
tested with most of the drug dealers
adding lethal amounts of medications
that are meant to be used for farm
animals into the drug Supply there is
now more than ever no such thing as a
safe
experience the only choice we have is to
interrupt the drug flow from entering
the state of New Hampshire and
discourage at every turn not encourage
more drug
use Mr Speaker HB 470 gives a disturbing
false sense of security these reasons
alone are enough to vote no on the ought
to pass motion so another potion can be
made thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
mes thank you Mr
Speaker at the end of
2023 uh I read an article online that
projected the total number of drug
overdose deaths in the United States uh
for
2023 to be
112,000
people so to to basically put a picture
around that that's just about the size
of the population of
Manchester now a lot of us in this room
have been here before uh over the years
uh We've included things in the budget
and we've included uh new programs that
actually strengthen and Empower law
enforcement to enforce our drug laws
we've also invested in things like
prevention and treatment for people uh
who are addicted to drugs and last year
one of the really good things that we
did was we passed a bill legalizing
fentanyl test strips and xylazine test
strips those are called drug checking
materials and one of the issues that
we're having right now is that anytime a
new technology comes
along we're in a position where we
actually have to pass a law to start
using it we have fentanyl test strips in
our rsas we have xylazine test strips in
our in our rsas we have nxone as an
opioid reversal agent in our rsas but
for us to use other things that are that
are basically in development as they
come along and to be able to get them
out into a situation where they can help
people we're sort of caught in this trap
where we need to pass a law to do this
what this bill does is it gets us out of
that
trap in essence what we're doing is
we're legalizing and and and essentially
agreeing not to prosecute people for
possessing an extremely small amount
amount of a drug for testing purposes
only if they're caught with a bag of
drugs and a fentanyl test strip a
fentanyl test strip or another kind of
test strip isn't a get out of jail free
card for anybody you're still going to
be prosecuted under the law and this
Bill calls for
that what one of the reasons why we need
bills like this is we are not in a
static situation when it comes to our
epidemic of drug
overdoses uh there's a new fentanyl like
compound that's actually starting to hit
the streets in other states called
nine nine is two to 50 times more
powerful
than
Fentanyl and unfortunately a fentanyl
test strip will not detect
nine to my knowledge there are no nine
test drips available at this
point I I don't know if there's any kind
of a test kit that's in development uh
that's going to hit the street soon but
what I do know is that nine and other
compounds like it are actually things
that will show up in Laboratory Testing
so one of the other things that this
bill does as part of
this oh I'm sorry one of the other
things that this bill does is is it
actually makes it legal for
organizations that provide harm
reduction services and that are
authorized by the state uh like harm
reduction agencies uh to actually test
drugs and uh the lab equipment that they
use uh also would be exempt under the
law
one thing I think we need to realize
when we're talking about quantities like
10 milligrams uh and that's the nominal
amount that's part of the bill is that
this is an extremely small amount and
we're talking about people who are
addicted to drugs so to give you an idea
what 10 milligrams of powder looks like
that's enough powder to cover the beard
of Abraham Lincoln on a
penny um so I I don't dispute the fact
that there are some drugs that are out
there that if you have that quantity of
of drug it it can kill you if you ingest
it the issue that we have is that to
make drug checking practical people need
to be able to test a certain amount of
the drug try and hold that amount of
powder or try to put that amount of
powder in a bag this is this is one of
the one of the things that we're up
against right now if we want to make an
impact and we want to save lives these
are the sort of decisions that we
actually have to be prepared to make we
have to decide which which is more
important we're we're in a position if
if somebody is actually caught with more
drugs and is caught with drugs with
possession to sell there's nothing in
this bill that is actually going to keep
that person from being
prosecuted nothing at all all that we're
saying is that if you and this this
could be somebody's son Somebody's
Daughter somebody's wife somebody's
husband but if if you're in a position
where you have a small amount of drug
and you want to know what's in the that
pill before you take it or what's in
that powder before you ingest
it you have that ability you have the
ability to save yourself because the
problem the the problem that we have
with the problem that we have is we
can't turn people around we can't get
people into recovery after they're
dead what this does is give people
another chance and gives them an
opportunity to make a decision not to
take a drug and maybe to take other
decisions that could really change the
course of their lives this is an
extremely an extremely important bill uh
and uh colleagues I I urge you very
strongly uh to give it strong
consideration and and please please pass
it thank
you the motion before us the committee
the majority committee report of autop
pass autopass has amended on Bill
470 a roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
[Music]
seats
the mo motion before us is the majority
committee report of autop pass as
amended an House Bill 470 this is a roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative Roy for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the amount of drugs
authorized in this bill would kill
people and Mr Speaker if I further know
that one
grain of car fenel if if it gets on your
skin can cause you to overdose and die
would I vote against this bill so that
people who work around this in law
enforcement and other services do not
die and the law can continue to be
enforced J recognize as representative
newel for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr chair if I know that there
are tools available to help our
communities respond knowledgeably and
effectively to the ever changing and
ever more life-threatening emergency
that we face if I know that providing
for the responsible utilization of such
tools would mitigate the risk of the
kind of devastating loss that myself and
so many other Granite Staters have
experienced and continue to experience
and that in this very moment in this
body we have the capacity to pass policy
that will save precious lives would I
now press the green button to pass this
life-saving
legislation motion before us a majority
committee report of a to pass has
amended on House Bill 470 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you oppose
you'll press a red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
all members present had an opportunity
to vote El will attend this day of the
vote 212 voting
a61 voting a committee report is
adopted
committee on criminal justice Public
Safety to which was referred Senate Bill
249 FN act relative to the release of a
defendant pending the trial and
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment recommendation
to Bill ought to pass with Amendment
Senator Linder Harriet goth for the
committee
okay it's all
listed the amendment is 2461 in House
calendar
49 the question is on the amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay eyes have
it amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment a division has been requested
there is no debate members take your
seats
clear
the motion before us is a to pass with
Amendment on Senate Bill 249 FN this is
a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppose you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
parsh can't push the button thank you
Solan
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 361 voting a seven voting aay
committee report is adopted and it's on
its way to
finance
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 147 relative to
membership of the advisory committee on
the education of students with
disabilities chair recognizes
representative
Miler thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to
move to table this motion thank you
tabling motion is in order the motion
before us is a table house bill
147 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and HB 147 is laid on
the
table Jo the committee on education to
which was referred House Bill
267 act relative to criminal record
checks in school employment considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study sen Valerie McDonald
from majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment sen of Glenn cordelli for the
minority of the committee the chair
recognizes representative
lad thank you very much Mr uh speaker I
move to I'd like to make a motion stage
motion I'd like to table HB
155 excuse me 267 that's on consent uh
267 the motion before us is a table
House Bill 267 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I oppose n the eyes have it and House
Bill 267 is laid on the
table
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 3 54 relative to
chartered Public School eligibility for
state school building
Aid this comes without
recommendation Rec representative
McDonald moves a to
pass and bringing forth the amendment 2
415h printed in house record 49 Pages
67-69 motion is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those paos next
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass as Amendment the chair
recognizes representative
luno thank you very much Mr Speaker good
morning and I'm standing here to speak
against the motion of ought to pass as
amended let me be clear your vote
against the motion is not a vote against
Charter
Schools okay okay your vote against this
motion is not a vote against charter
schools and it's not a vote against
opportunities for kids it's a vote
against a bad policy that needs more
work the bill makes changes to the state
school building aid program a program
that was recently reinstated after a
10-year pause and now has over $200
million of proposed building projects in
its in its
backlog the building aid program is
important to make sure Public Schools
provide a safe clean and up-to-date
learning environment to the over for the
over 160,000 kids across our
state the program provides grants to
reduce the burden on local property
taxpayers these grants are paid for
through a variety of state taxes but not
property
taxes these grants help to reduce your
constituents property taxes
this bill is amended would change the
program and allow the New Hampshire
Department of Education to award
building Aid grants to privately owned
and managed charter
schools and it's on top of existing law
that already provides charter schools
with $50,000 a year to cover facility
costs and $46 million in federal grants
that can be used for construction and
renovation projects for new and existing
Charter School
R but why is the bill is amended
irresponsible because it's open to fraud
and misuse and leaves State taxpayers
holding the bag when a charter school
goes out of
business over the decades 10% of charter
schools in New Hampshire have ceased
operations for reasons including low
enrollment insolvency and
fraud proponents will say the amendment
per Checks taxpayers In in the event a
charter goes out of business but
actually it does nothing about that if a
public school were to cease operation or
discontinue the use of a building that
benefited from the building aid program
the state has to be paid back but no
such provision would apply to charter
schools in this
bill currently the Departments of
Justice and education are working to
strengthen the financial standards for
Charter Schools let's not create new
loopholes for financial fraud and misuse
with this bill I'm asking you to vote no
on the motion of ought to pass as
amended so that we can continue to work
on this bill during the interim uh study
period and Mr Speaker I do ask for a
division vote thank you very much chair
recognized representative
McDonald thank you Mr Speaker honorable
colleagues according to RS a
1985b chartered Public Schools should be
permitted to apply for building Aid
House Bill 354 repeals a contradicting
statute so this one can be operative in
the same manner as the public school
infrastructure Fund in other words the
passage of this bill will not result in
Monumental change to statute but it will
have monumental impacts in the lives of
New Hampshire students for families
seeking an alternative education
chartered Public Schools adapt so every
student can
Excel gifted students Prosper placing
New Hampshire Charters among the top in
the country for highest test scores
based on nape better known as the
nation's report card while increasing
the graduation rate seven of New
Hampshire's charter schools are
dedicated to helping at risk youth who
may otherwise drop out of school as
these graduates seek high high education
a provision of House Bill 354 as amended
ensures successful transcript transfer
so students can flourish in college and
Beyond furthermore the primary aim of
house bill free5 for is to enable
chartered public schools to apply for
State Building Aid which traditional
public schools have always been able to
do chartered Public Schools would need
to complete the same application and
demonstrate the same need as traditional
public schools yet unlike traditional
schools who receive funds upfront
Charter Schools would grab gradually
receive Aid which adds the burden of
raising funds prior to construction but
in addition Charter Schools would only
be eligible to receive 30% of
construction cost whereas some
traditional schools receive up to
60% consequently House Bill free 54
enables charter schools to apply to
maybe be granted half of the funds that
traditional schools already receive and
have always
received finally Charter School
enrollment has increased
35% since prior to the pandemic several
of the existing 32 charter schools have
weight lists and three new charter
schools have been approved to open this
year with such extraordinary high demand
we need to to ensure students have a
place to learn so please join me in
voting yes on House Bill fre 54 and Mr
Speaker I am requesting a roll call vote
thank you does the member yield the
questions I no questions thank you
member does not
yield the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill
354 a roll call has been requested by
McDonald is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your
seats
clear
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
354 this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
Miler for a parliamentary
inak
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that there is
currently a severe limit to the
availability of State funds for building
Aid and that there's a large backlog of
building age
requests and if I know that charter
schools are privately owned and
independently managed and that there are
serious questions as to whether or not
public tax dollars should be allowed
allocated for construction of private
schools and further that there is
current issues around the disposition of
those assets should a charter school
cease to
exist and finally if I believe that this
bill is better placed into interim study
status as a full review of building Aid
and the process of building Aid is
currently being conducted by the
Department of Education
for those factors Mr Speaker I urge the
assembly to vote no and press the red
button thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
Vlad for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr
Speaker if I know this bill is not about
leased charter schools which are
eligible to receive up to
$50,000 per year but it's about charter
schools that are not eligible for that
money and not eligible for the charter
school building Aid that we're proposing
right here if I know as amended this
bill requires any Charter Charter School
applying for school building Aid to be
owned by the Charter Public School and
to have an asset
disposition plan approved by the state
board before applying for building
8 if I also know since
2019 Charter Public School enrollment is
up
35% to 5,700 students with many fine
Public Schools such as North Country
Charter linart classic Academy in
Peterboro and the academy for Science
and design that is recognized by the US
Department of Education as a National
Blue Ribbon
School and if I know many New Hampshire
Public Charters have faced classroom
space needs in recent years as
enrollment and Charters continue to grow
steadily and the limitations of their
original startup space makes expansion
difficult and lastly if I believe that
all public students in this state
regardless enrollment in an approved
Public School A District public school
or a public charter school deserve the
opportunity to learn in a safe clean an
upto-date building would I then press
the green button in support of charter
schools receiving building Grant support
thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 354 this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you
oppose you press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
for
represent
GRE of all members president an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote
190 voting a 177 voting a the committee
report is adopted pres a page declared a
conflict of interest that did not
participate major majority committee on
education to which was referred House
Bill 437 FN relative to reading
assessment and Intervention Program and
considered the same report the same the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study of Miler for majority
of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass from S Glenn cordelli from The
Minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative
Miler thank you Mr Speaker I move to
table representative Miler mov the table
House Bill
437 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I nay you eyes have
it and House Bill 437 is light on the
table committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 439 FN relative
to the duty to provide an education and
contracts with private schools it comes
to us without recommendation the chair
recognizes representative
Miler thank you Mr Speaker I move to
table presat Milo moves to table House
Bill
439 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and House Bill 439 is
laid on the
table
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 505 FN relative to
comprehensive mental health education in
schools comes to us without
recommendation the chair recognizes
representative
Miler thank you Mr Speaker I move to
table Senator Miler moves to table House
Bill 505 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I iOS
nay the eyes have it and house house po
Bill 505 is laid on the
table committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 553 relative to
school district information on personal
salaries come to us without
recommendation chair recognizes
representative
cordelli thank you Mr Speaker I move
that house bill 553 be laid on the table
Senor Celli moves at House Bill 553 be
laid on the table are you ready for the
question and all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it and
House Bill 553 is laid on the
table committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 577 FN local
relative to state aid for special
education pupils come to us without
recommendation chair recognize your
representative
Miler thank you Mr Speaker I move to
place 577 on the table Senator Miler
moves at House Bill 577 FN local be laid
on the table are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos n the guys have it and House Bill
577 is laid on the
table
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 628 FN requiring
certain non-public schools or education
service providers that accept public
funds to perform background checks and
all employees and
volunteers this comes to us without
recommendation s Tana moves a to pass
with Amendment the amendment is
2300h printed in house record 49 Pages
95 question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor the division has been requested on
the amendment members will take their
seats
h
C
the motion before us is the is the vote
on house on on the amendment
2300h this is a division vote on the
amendment if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
seconds
represent
for yes or
no represent
wood represent
bber represent
Crawford
represent
rolds represent
rolds I can't
see
repres representative leapley and
representative fellows thank you
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also will attend to state of the
vote 181 voting a 189 voting a the
amendment
fails to pass the question now is on
ought to
pass chair recognizes representative
dry
thank you Mr
Speaker fellow legislators I rise in
opposition to the a to
pass this bill checks for all employees
and volunteers at private schools and
other educational entities that accept
Public Funding this primarily affects
non-public schools and
homeschoolers non-public schools already
do background checks the non New
Hampshire non-public school advisory
Council reports reports that all the
schools associated with that Council
already do background
checks the private schools that are
accredited by the New England
Association of schools and colleges
have background check
requirements in addition a quick survey
of the non-public schools in my five
Town District included a College Prep
High School a monor school a religious
school and an unaccredited school and
they all already do background checks
not only do these non-public schools do
background checks many go above and
beyond the legal requirement for public
schools they do training for both both
staff and students they do yearly at a
station to stay up to
date they do it for reasons like
accreditation policy requirements
insurance
requirements but mostly because it's the
right thing to do non-public schools
have to compete for students in today's
climate one administrator said they
would be foolish not to do background
checks and through the federal Adam wall
act non-public schools have access to
the same federal background checks that
public schools
do but this is not the case for
homeschoolers who accept educational
Freedom
accounts HB 628 requires that any
employee or selected designated
volunteer providing instruction to a
person to an with an EFA
student has to have a background checked
though still schooling at home home
schoolers who accept EFA funds are by
law no longer considered homeschoolers
but have become EFA
students these homeschoolers turned EFA
students do not have access to the
required background checks individual
private citizens cannot run background
checks on other private citizens and
even if they could where would the
results be
sent the result results can only be sent
to a state agency the EFA law clearly
recognizes that parents are not agents
of the state the scholarship
organization running efas is not an
organization of the state an asent of
the state nor is any educational service
provider that accepts payments from an
EFA an agent of the
state does this mean that anybody
associated in person with any part of a
homeschool turned IFA program has to
have a piano um a background check
Someone Like a Piano PI teacher another
mom in a homeschool weekly Co-op or even
relatives be besides the
parents and speaking of
parents what we call traditional
homeschoolers are not affected by this
but what happens who continue to
families who continue to school at home
but take EFA funds they're same parents
same venue same program but their
student is now an EA
student these are in-person instructors
of an EFA student remember what the law
requires of EF inperson instructors of
EFA
students there are too many unanswered
questions here does this bill require
background checks on efa's homeschooling
parents or anybody else who provides
instruction to an EFA
homeschooler who would request the
checks who would pay for them or is this
an unfunded mandate who would monitor
compliance who would receive the results
is there even a penalty for
non-compliance this legislation doesn't
answer any of these questions and it
makes requirements without providing the
means to
comply that's the very definition of
inexpedient to
legislate
non-public schools are already doing
background
checks and the requirements on this bill
for homeschoolers with educational
Freedom accounts is completely
unworkable please vote no on this motion
so that another appropriate motion can
be made and Mr Speaker I request a roll
call
vote J recognize repr of Tanner
thank you Mr
Speaker the house education committee
has dealt with several bills over the
last few sessions relating to
identifying crimes and procedures for
criminal history records checks
background checks for those who work and
volunteer in
schools and
currently our Public Schools charter
schools and approved Publicis are
required by law to follow the procedures
outlined in RSA 190 189 colon
13 that address the process for
obtaining these records checks for all
employment and designated volunteer
positions in addition this statute
identifies 21 specific crimes uh related
to um
children that include murder incest
human trafficking assault sexual assault
child endangerment kidnapping indecent
exposure child pornography prostitution
manslaughter and the possession of drugs
with the intent to sell that immediately
disqualifies the individual from
employment 189 13 requires the employer
to develop procedures and policies to
review other criminal histories that may
be
reported House Bill
628 addresses a gap in our current RSA
which only suggests but does not require
these procedures for criminal history
record checks for employees and
volunteers of non-public schools and
educational
service providers that receive taxpayer
resourced Public Funding through
education Freedom accounts and
children's scholarship
accounts the intent of this bill was
never to apply to traditional in
homeschooling situations in fact that's
what the amendment was to make perfectly
clear the term designated volunteer is
in statute and does not apply to the
occasional
volunteer or parent
helper before working with children
Public School Employees and designated
volunteers are required to submit to a
New Hampshire State Police criminal
history records
check that includes State records and an
FBI National search using
fingerprints these states and federal
checks ensure that people with criminal
Behavior who are who are trying to avoid
being identified by changing their
personal information will be
found some of the nonpublic schools and
educational services do do background
checks however some of these background
checks are often done through
third-party vendors or simply internet
searches that can easily miss these
individuals that are
hiding our committee received several
stories from adults who told us of the
ab AB they suffered as
children their stories were tough their
stories mirrored most child abuse cases
our abusers are often a trusted adult
someone we might never expect of being
an abuser like a family member a family
friend or an authority figure like a
group leader coach teacher guide or
religious leader their parents were
totally unaware of the abuse and when
they found out it was too late it
drastically changed their lives and the
lives of their family
forever parents are often unaware that
Educational Services they seek out are
not required to do federal criminal
history background checks or for that
matter any criminal history check HB 628
will give parents taxpayers and the
state a way to trust in verify that all
schools Educational Services and
organizations that are receiving our
taxpayer resourc Public Funding will
screen their applicants for employment
and volunteer positions through the FBI
criminal history
checks HP 268 assures parents and
taxpayers that a policy and procedure
will be followed to identify convicted
criminals who should not be working with
children
this legislation sets up procedures for
criminal history background checks to
protect children voting for criminal
background checks should never be
dismissed because of the risk that it
might be too
inconvenient too intrusive or too
expensive the duty and obligation of
this legislature and the state is to
ensure the safety of all children in all
settings as best as we can from any
adverse and horrifying experiences that
will negatively affect them and their
families for the rest of their lives I
urge you to vote for this Bill thank you
does a member yield a
questions does does a member yield to
questions no member does not
yield the motion before us is the autop
pass motion on House Bill
we've had a request for a roll call from
representative dry is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
clear
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill
628 this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognizing representative Celli
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill would impose government
mandates requiring background checks on
private schools but they are already
being
done if I know that this bill would
require Visitor Center staff to get
background checks if a tour group
included a student who had an EFA
account but how would they
know and if I know that homeschool
parents would be required to have
background checks in order to educate
their own children would I Now quickly
kill this legislation that aims to
substitute government for parents by
pressing the red
button also be in
order you recognize representative Damon
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker good
morning colleagues if I know as a parent
and a grandparent that the safety of our
children is of utmost
importance and if I know that where a
child is educated does not change the
need for safety yet private schools and
education organizations are not
currently required to do background
checks if I further know that this bill
only applies to non-public school and
education services if they receive
taxpayer resourced
funding if I know as a survivor of abuse
by a family member that most child abuse
cases involve a trusted adult and
finally if I know this bill simply
protect students by requiring the same
comprehensive Federal criminal
background checks used in public schools
routinely would I now protect our
students by pressing the green button
thank
you motion before us is ought to pass on
House
Bill House Bill
628 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
second
represent
Phillips represent
Phillips
represent have all members present had
an opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the
vote
174 voting aay 199 voting
nay representative dry moves inexpedient
to
legislate
I he was just saying you made the
motion the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
628 are you ready for the question roll
a roll call has been requested who
requested it who requested
representative Miler requested roll call
that it is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call
vote
the motion before us is inent to
legislate on House Bill 628 this is a
roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
committee
report
fails the mo the motion of itl
passes majority committee on education
to which was referred House Bill 651 act
authorizing the Department of Education
and local school district to contract
with Transportation Network companies to
provide School transportation services
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator David
luno for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with a
following Amendment the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment representative Glenn cordelli
from The Minority of the committee chair
recognize representative cordelli thank
you Mr Speaker I move that house bill
651 be laid on the table the motion
before us is to lay house bill 651 on
the table are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay no the eyes have it and House Bill
651 is laid on the
table committee on education to which
was referred Senate Bill 151 FN relative
to mental health education comes to us
without recommendation sen of Damon
moves ought to pass the chair recognizes
representative
lad thank you Mr
Speaker this bill is re uh regards
mental health in our
schools and this is a topic which we
need to take
seriously the mental health of our
students is definitely aligned with
academic and social progress no
question but what we have to be very
careful in this bill with is that where
we're putting mental health it's going
to be put in this bill in RSA 193
e2a that's the substantive criteria for
an adequate
education we already have in this area
of statute statutory language for health
education mental health Nutritional
Health physical health are all part of
health
education this bill is
duplicative and it's not needed
secondly we have a health
curriculum and standards for health
which our state board approved they were
approved back in
the guidelines for health curriculum
specifically have a whole chapter a very
thorough chapter on Mental Health which
must be taught in
schools elementary middle and high
school they contain the standards for
mental health they're already
established those standards were
approved by the state board and approved
by jel
car
thirdly we also had a grant approved for
implementation the
mtssb that's the multi- system of
support for mental health behavioral
issues in
schools and as a prior teacher myself an
administrator for some 30 years this is
a program we do need and we also
appropriated $900,000
in hb2 and FY 23 for the purpose of
providing grant money where mtssb can be
used in schools it's a three- tiered
system in which the first tier is one
which is done by the class from teacher
it deals with you know when you went to
school there's a report card one side is
behavioral you take that side home and
show it your father your mother and they
all ripped off at you because your
behavior wasn't paring your good
academic side of the calendar or the of
the of the report that's the teacher job
is to recognize students which are being
hammered by mental health issues where
it's being brought in through our
society through social media or lack of
parenting at home or just a number of
other issues including
bullying the second tier in this is a
tier which we recognize and through our
school
psychologist that there is a risk here
for those students and we deal with that
the third tier here deals with reporting
to psychiatrists and MDS outside the
school system the school system is not
getting in the business at teaching what
you should think or what you shouldn't
think in regard to this topic so I want
to be very careful that we recognize
that mental health is a serious issue in
our schools in our society and it's
brought on for many different
reasons but put yourself in a
classroom as a teacher
and you have a student that's just
thrown a desk across the room which
happens or puts their hand through the
sheet rock in the wall of the the
building that happens too there has to
be a way of dealing with this and it's
happening more frequently especially
since we've gone through
covid but what we can't let happen we
cannot let this bill go into effect it
will put another subject that's over
already a component within Health in the
adequacy
formula and that's going to result in
many many other issues and
consequences so the recommendation
that's coming from the from us right
here against this bill is that it should
not go forward we already have mental
health addressed in
Statute in state board rules and through
program programs that are being used in
our schools and through funding as a
result of hb2 thank
you J recognized representative
Damon thank you Mr Speaker and good
morning again
colleagues I stand before you to urge
you to support OTP on SB 151 to require
mental health education in in schools
with respect to my colleague who just
spoke and defined the tears of
mtssb it's a great protocol and it is
not required it is not present in all
schools we cannot rely on that to
provide our students mental health
education let me back up a minute to the
basics mental illnesses are acute or
chronic illnesses they affect an
individual's emotional psychological and
social well-being and sometimes our
Behavior they are very common if you
look at the national statistics at least
a third of those of us in
Representatives Hall today have or have
in the past dealt with mental
illness they're not aberant they're just
part of some
people's construction if you
will these conditions include not only
but most commonly depression anxiety
substance use disorder schizophrenia and
mood or personality
disorders this bill originated and I
think this is very important by respect
of the governor's youth advisory Council
the students are asking us to help them
be more educated about mental
health we heard poignant testimony from
teens who did not receive mental health
education in their
schooling I recall one particular young
woman last winter a high school senior
now in college who spoke about her
friend and she driving along and then
her friend is in the midst of a panic
attack and neither one of them knows
what it is or what to do the woman who
testified the young woman was Googling
madly and trying to get get her friend
to pull over and thank goodness no lives
were lost had she had mental health
education she would have been better
aware immediately of how to help her
friend 15 or more perc of New Hampshire
youth suffered from at least one major
depressive episode in the past
year suicide is the second leading cause
of death with alarming increases in the
last several years
years these are all related to mental
health it is important to be very clear
that this bill does not in any way
provide diagnosis or treatment of mental
health conditions that's not the role of
Education
professionals what it does is simply
include education on Mental Health
disorders in curriculum the same way
that we inform students of
cardiovascular disease of
diabetes of common physical
conditions this legislation could help
decrease the stigma around mental health
that affects as I noted so many of us
from students to
Veterans I urge you to join me in
supporting this bill and I will note
that it passed across the wall by a
Voice vote thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill
5151 are you ready roll call roll call
has been requested by ribson of luno is
that sufficiently second it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your
seats
C
the motion before us is ought to pass in
Senate Bill
151 this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognize representative Vlad for
a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know mental health
standards are currently identified as a
key component of Health and Wellness
within the adequacy standards and if I
also know the health education
curriculum guidelines and accompanying
stand standards approved by the state
board already address mental health
curriculum for the elementary middle and
high school grades so this bill is not
needed would I then press the red button
so a subsequent motion of itl can be
brought
forward chair recognize representative
Woodcock for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker good
morning all let me re reiterate this if
I know that this bill does not provide
diagnosis or treatment but rather peer
education this bill provide fact based
information for our high schools student
to student and if I also know that
suicide is the second leading cause of
death of our
teenagers and finally if I know that
this peer education of facts May save
the life of fellow classmates because St
students talk to students I would ask
you to vote green and perhaps Save a
Life with education thank you Mr Speaker
motion before is a to pass on Senate
Bill
151 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
all members present and an opportunity
to
vote house will attend to state of the
vote 183 voting aay 186 voting nay the
motion of autop pass fails sen Vlad
makes a motion of inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay eyes have
it for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker having voting on the prevailing
side of Senate Bill 151 I would move to
reconsider and urge the body to vote
now motion before us is reconsideration
on Senate Bill
151 a division has been
requested members take your
seats who asked for a roll call
represent Simpson for aoll call
Representative Simpson ask for a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote on the reconsider
ation
the motion before us is
reconsideration on Senate Bill
151 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you will press the green button
if you opposed you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
VI
[Music]
thank
you if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 183 voting y 187 voting nay the
motion of reconsideration
fails the committee on education to
which was referred Senate Bill 218 FNA
establishing an early educator
professional development Grant comes
without recommendation chair recognizes
representative Vlad i' like to make a
motion Mr Speaker State your motion I'd
like to lay uh 218 on the table the
motion is to lay 218 FNA on the table
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those suppose nay the
guys have it in house bill Senate Bill 2
18 FNA is laid on the
table we have two lunchtime
announcements the chair recognizes
representative
Susi and of Representative Duty will
come down you're
next there'll be a lunch in in the
cafeteria uh sponsor is future Insight
so come one come all thank
you chair recogniz representative dsy
for an
announcement okay after a short bathroom
break I'd like everybody to convene down
here the hillsbor from the Hillsboro
County delegation for uh a couple of
votes that we have to take thank
you also be in recess
until
1:15
majority of the committee on Election do
to which is referred House Bill 115 an
act relative to change in the date of
the state primary election having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment Senate Ralph B for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being not
will agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate C vsberry for
the minority of the
committee the amendment is
22708 printed in house record
49 page 52 to
53 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I those
oppose nay the eyes have it committee
amendment is
[Music]
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment Barry has
requested a division vote members take
your seats this will be a division
vote
e
members take your
[Music]
seats
in
the the house will be in
order the motion before us is ought to
pass with Amendment this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
e
representative Boger
thank
you representative
Ms representative
voice
represent
King represent
makoni you can't push the button thank
you representative
Petri how would you like to vote
sir represent Kennedy and kushman I'll
take yours too thank
you represent Kennedy thank
you representative m Stapleton Kelly and
seway thank
youle to take
pictures repr
love Representative Steven
boy represent Perez thank
you uh representative there's no flash
photography on the
floor
smart okay I think that's
everybody if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 281 voting yay 82 voting aay
committee repor is
adopted representative Lane is here now
committing on Election law to which was
referred House Bill 116 FN an act
relative to fees and primary petitions
required for primary ballot election
access and considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation that the bill ought a
pass with Amendment sen Rasberry for the
committee
amendment is 2382 H printed in house
record 49 Pages 53- 54 are you ready for
the question on the amendment all those
in favor say I I those oppos nay the
eyes have it and amendment is adopted
the motion before us now is on a pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the committee report is adopted and it's
going to Ways and
Means
the house needs to become to order it is
way too
noisy majority of the committee on
Election law to which was referred House
Bill 345 FN an act enabling rank Choice
voting for State Party primary elections
in municip IAL elections having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Mr James quy
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Heath Howard from
the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative Ellen
Reed
okay we'll do it like this um so I just
the underlying Bill does nothing it's
just an enabling bill that enables
private parties which are private
organizations and municipalities by a
vote of the people to run their own
elections that's primaries and municipal
election by rank Choice voting if they
so
choose some of you who've been here for
a while know that this is not my first
rodeo when it comes to rank Choice
voting so I rather than talk to the bill
which someone else will do I wanted to
address a few common misconceptions
about rank Choice voting that you might
have heard you may have even said them
the first and and I want to say that
because I feel like this has become very
partisan nonsensically partisan and it
shouldn't be those who know me know that
while I have very very strong opinions
about a wide range of topics know that I
am no respector of party and that I
believe in doing the right thing and I
believe that the people of our state in
this country need to be represented by
their government so the first
misconception is that it's somehow going
to be confusing it would confuse voters
it would confuse the people who
implement the elections um if you
understand runoff elections then you
understand ranked Choice voting in fact
the other name for ranked Choice voting
is instant runoff elections and while
runoff elections which are meant to get
the majority winner in the cases that
you know someone has split the vote a
third party or an independent has split
the vote um runoff elections find the
majority the person with the most actual
support but they take time they take a
lot of money
and they they suffer from reduced voter
turnout instant runoff voting rank
Choice voting does all of it in one
ballot and in fact in southern states
that have runoff elections conservative
States their overseas military ballots
are ranked Choice voting ballots because
their overseas military personnel don't
have time to get a new runoff election
ballot sent to them exit polls in states
that have implemented rank Choice voting
whether on the municipal level or on the
state level States like New Mexico New
York Alaska Maine Minnesota Utah all
those exit poll show that the experience
of the voters 95% have a good or
excellent experience with rank Choice
voting they understand what to do they
understand how to cast their ballot it's
not difficult if you can rank your
favorite flavors of ice cream you can
rank your favorite
candidates further when it's been
implemented in places like
election workers and the Secretary of
State who had already been opposed to
the move to rank Choice voting once it
was implemented across the board had
positive results and no
problems another thing is this idea is
that rank Choice voting is somehow new
or technical um it's it's been in
existence for over a hundred years uh
some of the most conservative U modern
Western democracies in the world like
Australia and Ireland have been using it
for decades in the case of Australia
over a 100
years the Virginia GOP uses it
internally to determine their candidates
the Indiana goop uses it internally the
Utah GOP has used it for 30 years it's
been in use for over 100 years on the
municipal level in this country over 27
states have used it on the municipal
level and hundreds and hundreds of
universities and corporations have used
rank Choice voting including the Academy
Awards for decades the Robert rules
Roberts rules of order recommends a
method of voting that requires repeat
balloting which is what we do here when
we elect speaker if we have more than
two candidates we have if if you don't
have a majority winner somebody usually
drops and then everybody repeats the
ballot you can do that on one ballot by
simply saying who you would go for next
if your candidate is
dropped so it's not new and it's not
Technical and it's existed long before
our modern voting machines
the idea that is expensive Maine
implemented it for under
$100,000 or that it takes time Maine got
their results within 27 minutes of the
centralization of data now main law
allows towns one week to report their
results but we require our cers to CER
taper results to the secretary secretary
of state that night so we would have
results within 27 minutes that
night
the number one argument I've heard
though recently and I've heard it from
both parties is that in such and such an
election where they used rank Choice
voting my guy didn't
win what a weird argument first of all
in our current system can we not all
point to elections under our current
system where our person didn't
win the thing is is we shouldn't be
choosing systems based on whether or not
the person we like one we should choose
systems whether or not the majority of
the people like the winner we should
choose systems that actually represent
the people so if you like someone but
most people didn't then it's okay to
lose that's how it's supposed to
work so in closing this bill actually
does nothing it just we just today heard
arguments about local control it gives
local control if municipalities by a
vote of the people want to run their
elections in rank Choice voting manner
may have been beneficial to Manchester
this last time around for mayor um for
example then who are we to tell them
they can't do that if private
organizations like parties want to run
their elections by rank Choice voting if
they think it would be beneficial then
who are we to do that we just did a bill
earlier today we resoundingly defeated a
bill that would have told Banks how to
run their businesses so it's enabling
only it's not new or scary it's good for
the people and even if you vote against
this I welcome you to come to me and
talk to me personally about this issue
thanks J recognize representative
Mirad thank you Mr speaker thank you
fellow
Representatives want to just emphasize a
couple things about this bill it's an
enabling bill as you know doesn't Force
rank choices voting on any entity it
allows municipalities to use it if they
choose to that choice would have to be
governed by referendum or other legal
processes that embody the consent of the
government it allows parties to use
RVC excuse me RC if they choose to
wouldn't force it on any party just
allows it it would allow party to try it
out such as the Republican Party in the
state of Virginia has or the Democrat
ratic party in the state of Kansas many
other
parties would allow towns to try it out
towns that might want to be spared the
expense and inconvenience of having
runoff elections in over the course of
multiple
days I think that towns and parties
might opt for it might try it because
it's a system that allows us to really
figure out what candidate has majority
support in multi-member
basis and it encourages citizens to vote
their conscience to vote for the First
Choice candidate they really believe
in even if they're pretty certain that
that candidate won't win a majority they
know they won't be wasting their ballot
because their second choice could be
registered in the event that their first
choice candidate is eliminated so it
encourages citizens to Really voice
their first choice support and
communicate to parties and leaders what
they really think for that reason I
think that this bill makes sense and I
would encourage all my fellow
representatives to support
it chair recognized representative
quy thank you Mr
Speaker uh I rise in support of the
inexpedient to legislate motion on HB
345 uh as uh recommended in the majority
report of the house election law
committee I support this position
because I believe adoption of this
method of determining winners and losers
in our elections will cause a
substantial amount of damage to public
trust and confidence in our election law
our system of election
laws it's uh the legitimacy of our
entire system of governments depends
upon having the consent of the
government it's is so fundamental of
principle that in the Declaration of
Independence itself the founders of this
country held it to be a self-evident
truth that government's just Powers
derive from the consent of the
government now I see uh some
requirements the purpose of our election
law system is to ensure we have that
consent and the way our election laws
fulfill that purpose is by first uh
having an making an accurate assessment
of the sentiment of the public or the
the will of the people as we often call
it in doing so in such a way that uh the
system retains the confidence and Trust
of the public that a proper outcome has
been
achieved I'm going to focus on uh
on the need to retain the trust of the
public I see three elements that have to
be satisfied to do that
one our election laws have to be
transparent and by transparent I mean
they're reibly readily understandable by
everybody secondly they have to be
impartial and I mean particularly they
have to treat all candidates alike in
the same
fashion and
thirdly and I think New Hampshire law
has this
covered our elections have to come up
with a
uh an unambiguous result in a timely
fashion now I see that the concept
itself of rank Choice voting is having
some serious flaws in
particular with regards to
transparency and
impartiality let's contrast how the
current system determines winners and
losers it uses a plurality
approach basically that can be
summarized as those who get the most
votes win most votes wins a three-word
algorithm if you
will the rank Choice voting proposal
before us
today takes four pages to describe how
they would determine winners and losers
a page and a half of that four pages is
a list of 17 definitions of new terms
which you need to understand in order to
understand the two and a half pages of
uh explanation that follows and in my
view it's even worse than just 17
definitions these definitions what I
call nested if you read the first
definition or the second definition you
need to understand new terms that are
defined elsewhere in that
list this is not simple it's not
transparent it's not easy to understand
to to me it's as if you took the idea of
transparency and threw it out the window
and brick the window
up uh it's much more complex than most
votes
wins uh and I know from my own
experience in my profession that
complexity is the enemy of
transparency now with regards to
transparency we've covered that what
about
impartiality the proponents of this
approach to determine winners and
losers uh State
themselves that this uh this approach
will decrease the spoiler
effect now I don't I didn't see a
definition of spoiler in their
literature but it's clear from Context
it a
spoiler the people who are promoting
this approach would consider a spoiler a
person who basically has a low number of
votes doesn't have enough votes to win
but still affects the outcome
of the
election the proponents of this bill and
proposing to decrease the spoiler effect
are in essence saying that this system
would decrease the Electoral influence
and hence the political influence of
candidates who get to would never get
enough votes to
win it's it's showing a distinct bias in
my view against a certain type of
candidate another example of uh an in
built in bias according to the
proponents of this
approach uh is that it would uh
reward candidates who ran a campaign to
appeal to a a broad spectrum of uh
opinions well that again is using the
electoral system
itself to reduce the influence of a
certain type of candidate well in my
view that's not the job of the electoral
system the job of the electoral system
or system of election laws is to treat
every candidate equally with no inil
inbuilt bias and let the voters make the
decision on who should have more or less
electoral and Hance political
influence so to me these are just two
examples of serious flaws in this whole
concept that
would uh by by decreasing transparency
and impartiality voters are going to
recognize this and it will tend to
decrease their
trust and confidence in our electoral
system and I think will decrease the
likelihood of having their informed
consent this particular bill is uh
enabling rank Choice voting for
political party and Municipal
elections to me this violates another
principle that our election should
follow which is that all our voters all
our our citizens have the same rights
and I think they all should have the
same right to an equal degree of
transparency and impartiality in the
election law
system so for these reasons I support
the itl motion and I hope you'll join me
in that by voting yes on itl by pressing
the green button thank you for your
time representative Barry has requested
a roll call as that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your
seats
the motion the motion before us is any
speeding to legislate on House Bill
345 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative hamblet for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that rank Choice
voting enables voters to vote their
conscience
and if I know that rank Choice voting
would spare cities towns and political
parties the extra expense when runoff
elections are
needed and if I know that rank Choice
voting will increase voter turnout
because every voter's voice is heard and
if I know that house bill
345 is only an enabling bill that will
give municipalities and parties the
ability to opt in to rank Choice voting
for their own elections would I then
press the red button to defeat this itl
motion so another motion can be made
thank you chair recognizer have Senter
Barry for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr
Speaker if I know that we have another
rank Choice voting Bill coming up and if
I know that the debate will be riveting
is there as well uh would I now press
the green button to uphold the committee
report on rank Choice voting
motion before us is any meeting to
legislate on House Bill 345 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppos you
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 207 voting a 170 voting a committee
report is
adopted majority the committee on
Election law to which was referred House
Bill 350 act relative to rank Choice
voting having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate so James quy for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass to Jo hamblet for the minority of
the committee chair recognizer
representative
hamblet thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker House Bill 350 would establish
rank Choice voting for federal and State
elections for primary and general
elections my colleague on the other side
of the aisle is correct that the
legitimacy of our government depends on
the consent of the government rank
Choice voting improves our current first
pass the post election system to better
ensure that this consent
exists many Americans have lost faith in
our elections people think their vote
didn't count people see candidates
winning with a small percentage of the
votes if a candidate wins with 30% of
the votes that means 70% of the voters
wanted someone
else no wonder people are not happy with
the outcomes rank Choice voting will fix
these
problems rank Choice voting is
transparent and understandable it is
easy to cast a vote you simply rank your
choices it is easy to read the tallies
of the rounds of counting if there is
not a majority winner in the first round
is it easy to see how the ultimate
winner accumulated votes in each round
to reach a
majority voters can see that if their
first choice did not win their vote is
not thrown away their second or third
choice may end up winning every voter
will know that their vote
counted rank Choice voting is is
impartial it treats all candidates
equally no candidate is treated more
favorably than any other every voter's
vote carries the same value regardless
of how many rounds are needed just as if
each round was a separate runoff
election multiple courts have ruled that
rank Choice voting is
constitutional it is the best method for
arriving at the plurality winner that is
the candidate with the most
votes finally voters will not have to
read four pages of instructions to
understand how to
vote there will be Statewide trainings
to educate voters and officials on how
to Mark a ballot and how results are
tabulated voters get it the basic
premise is very simple choose which
candidates you support and rank your
choices on your
ballot rank Choice voting will renew the
Public's trust and confidence in our
elections as it is proving to do it is
it it is increasingly implemented across
the country people want to vote for the
candidates they truly believe in rank
Choice voting gives them that
opportunity please press the red button
to defeat this itl motion so that
another motion can be made thank you as
a member yield to
questions no member does not yield chair
recognizes representative
quy thank you Mr
Speaker this bill is almost the same as
the bill we talked about
previously
uh instead the difference is that this
bill would mandate the use of rank
choice voting in state and federal
elections all the numerous flaws which I
discussed for the previous bill would
still apply to the uh to this bill with
one
exception uh the exception would be that
in this case all voters would be
subjected to the loss of transparency
and
impartiality that would erode public
trust and confidence in our election
system so I ask that you join me in
voting for the itl motion by pressing
the green button thank you very much for
your
time senen Barry has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
motion before us is spe to legisl on
House Bill 350 this is going to be a
roll call vote chair recognized
representative Mirad for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know
that rank Choice voting of the sort this
bill would establish is used in the
state of
Maine and is much appreciated there by
Democrats and
Republicans and people from across the
political Spectrum if I know that rank
Choice voting of the sort this bill
would establish would conduce to Common
Sense government by electing candidates
who have a true majority support and if
I know that this bill would establish a
very simple system of instant runoff
elections in cases where candidates
don't have over 50% support in the first
round would I press the red button to
overturn the itl motion
chair recognize representative Barry for
a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the great state
of Maine is the great state of Maine and
if I know that things in the great state
of Maine might need to stay in the great
state of Maine and Mr Speaker if I know
that I have thoroughly enjoyed this
riveting conversation about rank Choice
voting would I now look and down at my
button and behold the green button so
that we may move on to the next
bill the motion the motion before us is
inexpedient to leg the majority
committee report of inexpedient to legis
on House Bill 350 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposer you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
Oella
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 248 voting a 128 voting a committee
report is
adopted
committee on Election law to which was
referred House Bill 447 FN act relative
to the purchase of election equipment
been considered the same report the same
with the following Amendment and
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment Senate Ross Berry for the
committee the amendment is 2366 H
printed in house record 49 Pages 73 74
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for question all those in favor
say I I those oppose nay the eyes have
it and amendment is
adopted representative burry has
requested a division members take your
seats
the motion before us is it pass with
Amendment on House Bill 447 FN this is
going to be a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button your
oppos you press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote
311 voting aay 62 voting a committee
report is
[Music]
adopted join the committee on Election
laot to which was referred House Bill
463 FN an act relative to the
establishment of an election informal
portal been considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment of Connie Lane
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate sen of
Clayton wood for the minority of the
committee the amendment is 2385 H
printed in house record 49 page 75 are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it
amendment is adopted chair recognizes
representative
maer thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon
everybody uh today I rise in firm
opposition to House Bill
463 this legislation in its current form
stands in Stark contradiction to the
ofal office we took under New Hampshire
RSA 42 col1 which binds us to uphold the
constitution of our great state this
oath is not a mere ceremonial gesture
but a solemn commitment to safeguard the
foundational principles of our
governance system however post Bill 463
with its proposed creation of an online
election information portal veers us
away from these crucial
foundations this bill's intentions to
modernize our voting system and enhance
accessibility are indeed
commendable yet it is the execution and
the potential constitutional conflicts
that raise serious concern s the
centralized collection and storage of
personal voter information a key aspect
of this bill presents significant risks
to privacy and data security in an era
where digital threats are increasingly
prevalent such a move could jeopardize
the sensitive information of our
citizens thereby infringing upon the
right to privacy enshrined in article 2B
of our
constitution just recently an ABC News
Report uh as recently as December 20th
hackers compromised a vulnerability in a
third-party vendor that serviced
exfinity
Comcast this led to customer information
being stolen nearly 36 million people
could be impacted by the hack according
to a filing from the Maine Attorney
General's office that's Maine our
neighboring
state Xfinity concluded on December 6th
that usernames passwords for some
customers um and other information were
stolen such as their contact information
last four digits of their social
security numbers dates of birth
Etc in April of 2023 the nashaa school
board was hit by a sophisticated Cyber
attack
um a school board member said I think
it's a horrible thing that this is
happening in our world today we were
told when we went paperless that the
internet was going to be the next
greatest
thing but obviously it's not
probably should just go back to paper
all we have to do is shred it when we're
done in August of 2021 the town of
Peterboro New Hampshire lost $2.3
million in taxpayer money as a result of
a Cyber
attack the US Secret Service told that
town that at least one other community
in Northern New England had also been
targeted to the tune of
$600,000 in California the Secretary of
State's office investigated how
information of 100 91 million voters was
exposed to the open internet due to a
misconfiguration of a database there's a
hundred more examples but you get the
idea uh moreover this bill's lack of
clear oversight mechanisms brings into
question the accountability of
government as outlined in article 8 of
our
constitution the concentration of
sensitive electoral data without
stringent oversight mechanisms is a
potential recipe for misuse of
information and the further erosion of
public trust in our electoral
processes Additionally the potential
restriction of portal access to specific
groups of people raises issues regarding
equal representation a Cornerstone of
our Republic underlined in part one
article 14 of the New Hampshire
Constitution by creating disperate
access to the electoral process HB 463
May inadvertently lead to unequal
representation and participation in our
Democrat atic
process given these significant
constitutional concerns I argue that
addressing the issues raised by 463 goes
beyond legislative action and calls for
a constitutional amendment as prescribed
in part one or part two article 100 of
the New Hampshire Constitution this is
not just about policy preferences it's
about adhering to our constitutional
duties and ensuring the Integrity of the
electoral system here in New Hampshire
in conclusion while the goal of HB 463
is to advance our electoral processes
its current form poses risks to our
constitutional mandates we must seek
solutions that both preserve our
constitutional rights and Foster
progress in our electoral system
therefore I urge my fellow legislators
to vote no on this bill and explore
solutions that align with our
constitutional principles and the oath
we have all sworn to uphold I also ask
for a roll call vote thank you
J recognize representative
wood thank you Mr speaker thank you
fellow colleagues I come here in
opposition of HB 464 I'll take a little
different approach than uh my
predecessor before me uh basically um
looking at the testimony at the original
Bill there was a lot of good reasons to
have a portal pretty much save paper
collect data easily make things easier
to read make things easier to change
these are the standard reasons why
people create
portals um this is one topic I do have
some knowledge of and the uh details are
the devil of of of any portal uh what
did come up in the discussion was
concerns about being connected to the
internet the obvious security concerns
and also just the validation of data to
make sure we know we're getting the
right uh material from the right people
um none of those were addressed in the
amendment the amendment is actually
quite interesting it doesn't address any
details or standards to follow When
developing a portal which is something
that has to be included how is this data
going to be validated it doesn't have to
be done to the bit level but you have to
know if you go into it a what we call a
proven standard uh when you look at a
lot of the discussion at the election
law committee uh it makes it sound like
we should already have a portal uh these
things are all over the place being used
standards are different in every portal
not all portals are the same if your
bank uses a system I'm sure your digital
signature is traceable to a proven
standard that is not a trivial thing to
do the uh Amendment brought up a couple
issues that I found interesting from the
technical point of view as amended we
remove verification by identification
age or domicile by affidavit under RSA
col2 now I can understand that because
by understanding affidavit it has to be
witnessed very difficult to do on the
internet it also showed another problem
Federal Law requires that had a sworn
statement be used for citizenship
supposedly citizenship is expensive
thing this is what I heard in testimony
it's an exp EXP expensive thing to prove
uh here's a case where this should be
addressed with the portal it should be
addressed to a standard uh but no no
standard was given is it going to be
mely a checkbox that we check every time
we go onto a new website and we do a
checkbox validation or is it going to be
something that really means anything I
don't have I I am on the election law
committee and I can't tell you that
answer so basically the last thing that
I so so technically we got a lot of
things to talk about and whether we have
a portal or don't have a portal uh we we
need to know what it can do and what it
can't do and that I don't think anybody
can tell you um the interesting thing
was it took out an interesting part of
handling and the validation of the data
uh what we found out if you read the
committee's report on the on uh special
committee on voter
confidence the people who are confident
in our committee in our process sorry
are people who deal with the locals all
the time uh the the biggest area of
confidence comes from the fact that they
know the people handling the data uh
when I try to challenge anything uh
people say oh that can't be handling in
our town because we Mary does such a
great job she's been doing it for 20
years now we get these people that we
want to increase the voter's confidence
that's what came out of this report so
I'm assuming that's one of our our our
objection our uh lost my mind sorry uh
one of our purposes uh we're taking that
away we're taking that Hands-On quality
that we have right now even though there
our problems that is a big confidence
Factor So based on confidence and the
concerns I believe that if we put one of
these things together we have to have
more focus on oversight verification
standards and details and for those
reasons until that bill comes along I
will not vote for HB 463 thank
you the motion before us is the majority
committee report of a pass as amended on
House Bill
463 sentive
Brennan let Rec
thank you Mr
Speaker HB 463 comes to this body with
bipartisan support from the election law
Committee in order to authorize the
Secretary of State to modernize voter
application processes through the
establishment of an election information
portal this bill as amended provides
Specific Instructions to the Secretary
of State to to develop the election
portal in consultation with our trusted
City and town clerks supervisors of the
checklist as well as the relevant State
departments and requires that voter
requests are processed by real human
beings in the appropriate municipal
offices for verification to ensure
oversight accountability and
accuracy so what can a voter do through
this election portal New Hampshire
citizens can begin the voter
registration process request an absentee
ballot and make changes like switching
their party affiliation or simply
correcting a spelling error on their
street
address this bill helps modernize an
outdated system makes checklist
maintenance easier for election
officials increases the accuracy of the
checklist and offers voters the
opportunity to choose the same kind of
convenience aord reped to them every day
when they conduct secure business and
banking transactions
online the election law committee heard
testimony about limited access to town
clerk's offices especially in our small
rural towns that may only be open a few
hours a week making it particularly
difficult to manage basic election
application processes for hardworking
citizens differently abled folks and
snow Birds spending a couple months away
from their
Hometown we heard about election
officials having extreme challenges
reading handwritten forms long lines
lengthy paper form processing time and
the desire of election officials to make
things more
efficient HB 463 resolves these problems
while maintaining local officials
important role in verifying voter
information as Citizens submit their
information directly to their trusted
local election official through the
portal committee members in the minority
raised concerns about
security but in a bipartisan fashion the
committee provided an additional layer
of security to alleviate the worries by
adopting an amendment that prohibits an
online checkbox affidavit for domicile
age and identification thus maintain
Ming review of submitted materials by
real human beings before making any
changes to the voter roles the
bipartisan majority agrees that
maintaining oversight and integrity in
the voting process is critical to our
continued successful election procedures
that have produced no widespread voter
fraud this bill has the support of the
Secretary of State who has made it a
priority to increase voter confidence
and the bipartisan majority agrees this
bill maintains election security
increases efficiency appropriately
balances the needs of election officials
and voters and municipalities will find
Financial Relief by Saving thousands of
dollars each election cycle as a result
of the portal from a decrease in paper
processing
costs Mr Speaker HB 463 is good for
granite sters good for election
officials municipalities it's good for
accessibility accuracy and democracy
it's time to embrace the 21st century
and modernize this small but significant
part of our election system in the
secure efficient manner outlined in this
bill and I encourage the bipartisan yes
vote this good bill deserves thank
you motion before us is the majority
committee report of Water Pass amended
House Bill
463 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I those oppose
nay and division has been requested only
people in the
room
e
she made the
speech she made the
speech
respect
the member had requested a roll call
which we were unaware of
so I am going to accept the motion for a
roll call if it is sufficiently
[Music]
seconded well it seems the request has
been
withdrawn so now we're back to a
division
vote and this this is a verification
vote of The Voice vote so the motion
before us is ought to pass as amended on
House Bill
463 this is a division vote to clarify
The Voice
vote if you're in favor you will press
the green button if you're opposed you
will press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
[Music]
representative
Gilman representative
Stringham representative
post represent
post thank
you all members present had opportunity
to vote house will attend us stay to the
vote 195 voting aay 172 voting a the
committer report is
adopted
chair recognizes as a clerk Mr Speaker
representative Wayne McDonald moves that
the house vacate the reference of House
Bill 1611 relative to establishing a
child care Workforce fund to the
committee on Health Human Services and
elderly
Affairs are you ready for the question
all favor say
y are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
y would you like to restate the
mood Mr Speaker representative Wayne
McDonald moves that the house vacate the
reference of House Bill 1611 relative to
establishing a committee childcare
Workforce fund to the committee on
Health Human Service and elderly
Affairs are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I suppose nay the eyes the eyes have
it it is referred to the special
committee on child
[Music]
care
majority of the committee on environment
and agriculture to which was referred
House Bill 369 an act to stablishing a
task force to provide energy relief on
farms and consider the same report the
same with the following am Amendment and
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment from Senate Peter beby
for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with a majority Report
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative Kevin verville for the
minority of the
committee the committee amendment is
2355 H printed in house record 49 Pages
69 through 70 are you ready for the
question on the committee of the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those poose
nay the eyes hav it the committee
amendment is adopted representative
Bixby offers floor Amendment
0015 it's in your seat
pockets are you ready for
question am you may speak to the
amendment Bixby has recognized to speak
to the amendment so uh the floor
Amendment uh is was the result of a
conversation I had with the member from
uh Barnstead and the former chair of my
committee who now is uh in the body on
the other side of the wall uh what the
commit the committee Amendment Narrows
the definition of a farmer uh narrower
than what is currently in State Statute
and um my uh colleagues pointed out that
this could inadvertently uh exclude uh
New farmers and be uh small farmers from
the program and they would in fact be
some of the most appropriate
beneficiaries so what the uh floor
Amendment does is it simply um makes the
definition of farmer uh consistent with
the current definition under RSA uh 21
colon 34A so uh please s support the
amendment thank
you the motion be for the motion before
us is the Bixby floor Amendment
0015 are you ready for the question on
the floor
Amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the floor
amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is a to
pass with Amendment the chair recognizes
representative
verville thank you Mr Speaker good
afternoon uh honorable colleagues uh I
rise in opposition to House Bill uh 369
and and I oppose this bill for for
several reasons uh I won't it's I won't
take up too much of your time but one of
the things that this bill
does is it creates
duplicative uh efforts and and
opportunities so all the things that
this bill proposes to do are currently
available all those Services all that
information is available uh from other
sources today so what this bill wants to
do is it wants to spend
$100,000 to contract with
UNH to have yet another source of all of
that
information and last I checked um last
year was the budgeting year and next
year will be another budgeting year and
I'm not saying that maybe this isn't a
priority but it is not such a priority
that we need to be spending
$100,000 to make duplicative uh
information available so I would say to
the people that that support this bill
it should be brought back during the
normal budgeting process and funded and
funded
then my other challenge is that it's
very narrowly focused right so this is
for Energy Efficiency this is um for
alternative energies you know so-called
green energies uh and things like that
but but focused only to
Farmers Only to
farms and not to the average citizen
that could also benefit from this
information but of course they can go
get that information in a whole lot of
other places because all this
information is currently available so we
want to spend $100,000 to contract with
un to bundle publicly available readily
available information and funnel it only
only to to
Farmers that to me is not a good use of
time it's not a good use of of money and
so for that reason I would ask you uh to
to press the shiny red
button uh to oppose the ought to pass so
that another motion can be made thank
you Mr
Speaker you recognize her representative
Bixby
thank you Mr Speaker the bottom line for
HB 369 as amended is that it will help
farmers get USDA and other grants that
will significantly reduce their energy
costs the USDA Rural energy for America
program uh reap grants are available
from uh to rural farms and small
businesses and small businesses are
defined with businesses that uh make up
to $50 million a year uh and and in New
Hampshire Farms are a very small
fraction of the grant recipients this is
because small larger small businesses
have the staff and time available to uh
to really design and uh fulfill the
application process small farms don't
really have this luxury uh they are
generally running on very short staff
farmers are um busy doing all the
business of the farm they don't have as
much time to do the research necessary
to get these uh grants what the bill
does is it provides a Cooperative
Extension field specialist contracted
through the Department of Agriculture to
provide advice for Farmers on uh energy
and and on on Farm energy and
engineering design identify resources
identify grants and loans that are
available and line up the resources to
help with the application
process a key advantage of advice from
uh the EXT extension rather than from a
vendor is that the extension has
experienced looking at the whole Farm
context and uh figuring out how to
maximize Farm efficiencies so this is
something that's really critical for New
Hampshire
agriculture if we want New Hampshire
agriculture to thrive and to provide a
larger uh percentage of the food that we
now eat and New Hampshire is way behind
even our neighboring states in terms of
how much we our Farms are able to
provide for uh uh in terms of our uh
food
budgets uh so if if we want to support
our Farmers we need to provide Farms
with the leverage they need to become
more efficient and
productive and providing an engineer
engineering and field advisor for New
Hampshire Farms will result in a
substantially longterm in substantial
long-term cost savings for New Hampshire
Farms please vote Yes to support our
hardworking New Hampshire Farmers vote
green for those crops thank you
representative Sweeney has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
e
clear
the motion before us is a pass as
amended on House Bill
369 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative kto for a
parliamentary
cour thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill is not ready for prime time as the
amendment brought forth does not address
all the concerns the committee
had and if I know that every County
already contributes to UNH extension
whom this money is slated for by all New
Hampshire
taxpayers and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that just last week the New
Hampshire Farm Bureau sent out
information about an on Farm solo
webinar with funding for this provided
by top transition to organic
partnership NOA New
Hampshire and the department of a
proving that there are already several
resources available to New Hampshire
Farmers interested in Energy Efficiency
and climate resilience would I now push
the red
button chair recognized representative M
chair recognized representative McGee
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill is the
result of a Seventh Generation New
Hampshire farmer who wanted to know why
the state of New Hampshire wasn't
helping Farmers to lower their enormous
energy costs when he had a friend who
was powering his entire operation uh
with tracking solar arrays um and he was
jealous basically um and if I know that
this bill was vetted by the Department
of Agriculture and then retained in
committee
and um amended to enable the UNH
Cooperative Extension to hire an advisor
that would provide Farmers with advice
on design funding and project planning
for current Energy Technologies that
could help them lower their bills and
keep them in
business and if I know that this bill as
amended directly impacts whether both
new and
longstanding and established Family
Farms are able to continue providing us
with locally grown produce which
improves our quality of life our
security and helps lower their costs and
therefore our costs then would I now
press the green button to create one
position at the co-op extension to help
farmers navigate cost-saving measures
through the approval of the New
Hampshire Farm Energy Systems advisory
program which they would otherwise not
have the time to be able to take the
energy to look into and centralize um
without this program and having the
advice in one place where they know how
to get it thank
you motion before us majority committee
report of a pass that Amendment on House
Bill 369 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 186 voting yay 187 voting nay
committee
report fails on motion to table
please it is proper
motion motion is in order to table House
Bill
369 are you ready for the question a
division has been
requested members take your
seats
no
the motion before us is to table House
Bill 369 this is a division vote house
will be in
order if you're in favor you'll press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
Bry Teresa can you send an email about
6 represent
Peterson
Hicks represent
m
you need to give me a thumbs up or down
thank
you all members present have an
opportunity to vote El will attend to
stay in the
vote 322 voting yay 54 voting aay House
Bill 369 is laid on the
table
majority of the committee on environment
and agriculture to which was referred
House Bill 602 FN an act relative to
lfil sighting consider the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment sen of Kelly
Penza for the majority of of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate sen of Kevin
verville from the minority of the
committee the committee amendment is
2333 H printed in house record 49 Pages
89 through 90 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay no have
it amendment is adopted Senate Penza
offers floor Amendment 0042 H it's in
your seat pockets and is recognized to
speak to her
Amendment good afternoon so the
amendment that's in your pocket takes
away one line from the bill that we just
approved it is
basically um saying that the
environmental rules remain in effect
until July 1 2025 or until the reopt
rules are effective hearing from my
colleagues that was an issue in possibly
kicking the can down the road with um
permitting rules that are going to be um
in effect that should be in effect this
summer the motion before us is the Penza
floor Amendment
0042 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
you eyes have it the floor amendment is
adopted chair
recognizes the question now is ought to
pass as
amended the chair the chair recognizes
representative
Penza
this amendment of HB 602 uh provides
requested guidance and direction for the
state agency which is Dees and is pro
business for the industry by
implementing a preliminary application
into das's new permitting rules in the
process currently New Hampshire's
landfill application process requires
the developer to submit each permit air
Wetlands solid bed etc in full before
Dees will R will review it this can be
very costly to the developer and to the
state as thousands of person hours in
staff and time are needed to rev review
a full application New Hampshire has
been lagging behind Most states for
decades with their permitting process
this bill brings New Hampshire in line
with a two-phase permit process that
will save both private and public money
hearing from Dees employee after this
amendment was proposed in our committee
which um was voted in
13-6 um even though they had they are
not publicly allowed of course to speak
for or against legislation the employees
stated that they were happy this
legislation was moving forward the main
reason was because the industry is
putting pressure on Dees before
submitting applications asking questions
about proposed locations this two-phase
permit process can help eliminate
eliminate the lobbying efforts which is
putting Dees employees in uncomfortable
positions this bill bill Milly asks Dees
while it is already revising the
relevant regulations to create a
preliminary application Phase so that
applications that are clearly illc
conceived can be rejected based upon the
evidence contained in a partial permit
application also those applications that
are that are based basically deemed
plausible can then proceed to a full
application which can be processed more
quickly than a single-phase application
since Dees will already have evaluated
the basic parameters of the location
proposed so rather than the old bill
which was you know 602 from last session
rather than that which was actually
writing you know statute or criteria
into the statute for Dees this is just
basically a preliminary application that
the legislature here can merely direct
which Dees is asking us to do all of the
time to develop such criteria on their
own which they are currently in the
process of doing based upon their own
judgment and comments from experts in
the public please approve this thank
you chair recognizer representative
verville thank you Mr
Speaker so the floor
Amendment what's it
fix so previous Bill said that we're
going to get a third party involved with
Dees for writing the new rules DS is
writing new landfill sighting rules I
don't know if you guys knew that they're
due to be complete this
summer thees expects to be finished with
their landfill rule writing this summer
and so the bill wants to get a third
party as of yet unnamed unknown so maybe
Pro business Maybe not maybe pro-
environment maybe not who knows you got
to wait to to find out you have to pass
the bill to find out who's going to get
the
contract
so the floor Amendment says well the
current rules will stay in effect if
they don't get the new rules done in
time because we're bringing this third
party in which could delay it by a year
or
two but what I hear on on both sides is
nobody seems to like the current rules
so if we pass this bill we're going to
enshrine the current rules which nobody
seems to like um until such a time as as
new rules get written by Dees with the
help of an unknown third
party one of my favorite refrains in
this in this body is trust our experts
trust our
experts we hire the state of New
Hampshire hire some of the best and the
brightest to do our work the work of the
state and we've entrusted them for
decades when I say them I'm talking
right now about Dees in writing landfill
citing rules and
regulations but now all of a of a sudden
when they're going to be done this
summer we don't trust them we want to
get a third party involved to give some
sort of advice that we don't really know
what it's going to
be how do you know the rules that de's
writing are
broken if they haven't been published
yet so this bill is a fix for something
that's being done that's not complete so
we don't we don't know if there's a
problem so what I'm really asking
for is to kill this
bill let Dees publish their new rules
and regulations for landfill
sighting and then and then if there's an
issue come back and correct whatever
issue we believe may or may not exist
that's what I'm that's what I'm asking
you to do
a two-phase permitting
process sounds like
fun right bite once if you're lucky you
get to
swallow bite twice find out can drag on
for forever can drag on forever the
current process well that's interesting
because my understanding is that a solid
waste um company the company that takes
care of solid waste is put in a new
permit for a location up north of which
we've heard about before that's really
what where this all comes from may or
may not be up by
Dalton and
Dees and this is just recently and DS
has already told them we're sorry we're
not really doing much with your permit
because it's incomplete so in a matter
of weeks a couple of months at
most DS has already said your your
application is incomplete that does not
sound like dragging on for an inordinate
amounts of time it seems to me that DS
is getting
applications working very efficiently
very effectively and getting back with
with the correct information um for all
parties in
involved I've I've seen a lot of emails
flying back back and forth about this
particular application and DEA s is
responding to parties on both sides of
this issue in an unbelievably timely
manner when we consider it state
bureaucracy right because bureaucracy
drags on well DS is not dragging their
feet so so I'm not
sure I'm not sure I agree with with any
of
that I'm on environment and agriculture
committee and you're going to see a lot
more bills like this Us in the next 6
months trivia question for you hasm
generated within the state of New
Hampshire where does it
go it goes out of state do you know why
do you know why it goes out of state
because New Hampshire does not have a
Hazmat remediation facility within our
state
boundaries and people are complaining
about the sighting of landfills in New
Hampshire and one the big complaints is
we're going to be importing trash well
we already import trash we export trash
trash goes both ways right Commerce
Clause allows
that so imagine if if New Hampshire put
a ban on the importation of
trash and other states did the same and
we start passing bills that make it
impossible to site a landfill in New
Hampshire because in my opinion that's
the endgame of this this type of
legislation is to make it so that we
cannot site landfills within New
Hampshire that means we would have to
export all of our trash so first we're
complaining that we're importing trash
but then we want to write rules
regulations and state law that will
eventually Force us to have to export
all of our trash that's not
fair that's not Equitable that is not
good public
policy
this is a difficult topic it really is
and the state of New Hampshire is not
perfect at this time I don't I don't
disagree with that at
all this fix is not the right fix it's
not the right fix at the right
time let's trust our experts let's trust
Dees to write the new rules and the new
regulations let them bring it to jel car
let the process play out let's see what
our our experts propose for us to help
us work through this and
then and then if we don't like what they
bring us then let us consider potential
corrective
actions right now the process is is on
time and working out as planned and
that's what we should do so for that
reason I'm asking you um to to to vote
against the uh the a to
pass and uh so another another motion
can be made thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize rep Sam
Gera thank you Mr Speaker wish my house
colleagues a happy New Year uh one of
the I think the most common question I
get from constit constituents uh back in
Kean and Chester county is do we ever
get anything done here on a bipartisan
basis uh and I'm happy to tell them we
do talk to them about the consent
calendar I talk about all the good
bipartisan work that we get done here uh
in conquered I'm proud to say that my
committee with leadership on both sides
of the aisle is an especially bike
partisan committee and we work hard to
come together on legislation that we
feel not only benefits the people of the
State of New Hampshire but has a very
realistic chance of getting bipartisan
support from our colleagues in the house
this piece of legislation is no
different despite our many differences
on a wide variety of topics this body in
this chamber has been consistent in our
bipartisan support when it comes to
protecting the environment and public
health when it comes to landfill
sighting as I said this bill is a
perfect example of the work that we have
been striving to do together when we
talk to the Department of Environmental
Services about the kinds of legislation
that will benefit them most in their
efforts what they tell us is that they
need a balance of clarity and
flexibility they need to know what the
direction is that the legislature is
providing but they also need us to
provide the flexibility that allows them
to write the kinds of rules that will
enact the will of the legislature that's
exactly what 602 Does this does not tell
Dees what they have to put as the
Criterion in the first stage it doesn't
tict dictate any range of policies any
contented policies with due respect to
my colleague I'm not really sure what
bill it was that he was reading before
he prepared his floor speech this bill
does not refer to any third party it
does not require Dees to go out and
bring a third party in to come up with
any list of requirements it's simply not
in the bill what what the bill says is
that
Dees will determine what the
disqualifying conditions would be and if
a an applicant submits an
application and it doesn't meet those
minimum requirements it simply gets
returned without prejudice by the way
this is a permitting application process
that these businesses deal with in
States all across the country they're
perfectly familiar with it it doesn't
dictate to Dees what those Criterion has
to be it doesn't require a third party
to come in and do any work to tell Dees
how to do their jobs my colleague I
think was absolutely right when he said
that we should trust our experts and
that is precisely what 602 is designed
to
do Dees is in the middle of rewriting
those rules I'm confident that they're
going to come up with a set of rules
that will will provide the type of
protections that we all want for our
constituents here in the granite
state the Draft rules as they are out
now for public review contain a very
strong statement already it says that
the footprint of a landfill and
Associated infrastructure shall be
located such that a discharge spill
leachate release or other failure of the
waste containment system or Associated
infrastructure I know sexy stuff will be
detected and assessed and Remediation
initiated prior to contamination
reaching any perennial water body that's
part of the rules that they're working
on right now that's a strong statement I
think that's a statement that we can all
get behind and we are simply asking for
at a first stage in this process that
will quantify what that means to give
direction to all of the applicants to
know this is what we're looking for that
Dees doesn't need to use unne necessary
time and neither does the applicant in
order to enter their permit to be
successful and to provide the
protections that we all want uh and need
for our constituents so I ask you all as
uh our committee members on both sides
of the aisle did to come together and to
support this legislation in the best
interest of Gran stator thank you Mr
Speaker pres Bixby has asked for a
division vote
this will be a division vote members
take your
seats
e
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 602 this is going
to be a division vote chair recognizes
representative ktoa for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know
that Dees is already kneed deep in
writing the rules and would like the
opportunity to complete them before more
legislation is thrown at them and if I
know that their rules are to be
completed in August of
2024 just a mere 7 months from now and
that we can help with the direction of
the rules by attending the public
hearings and being involved as
legislators and
citizens and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that we need to let the process
play out before we try to legislate what
should and shouldn't be in the rules
would I now press the red
button chair recognize representative
Simon for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that HB 602 has absolutely
nothing to do with third party
Consultants Mr Speaker if I know that HB
602 also has absolutely nothing to do
with um landfill citing criteria it
merely um require requires the
implementation of a preliminary
preliminary phase of the application
process and Mr Speaker if I know that
the two-phase landfill application
permitting process has been a standard
procedure across the country for decades
and furthermore Mr Speaker if I know
that implementing um a two-phase
application process can streamline this
process saving time and money not only
for the state but also more importantly
for the applicant would I then press the
green button and um support this Bell
thank
you
the motion before us the majority
committee report of Auto passit
Amendment onh House Bill 602 this is a
division vote you are in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
for
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 226 voting a 145 voting a committee
report is
adop
e
committee on executive departments and
administration to which was referred
House Bill 559 FN establishing a T State
retirement plan group for new state
employee members the retirement system
comes to us without
recommendation sen of Simon
offers a motion of ought to pass and
offers Amendment
246 printed in house record 49 Pages 87
through
89 chair Rec chair recognizes
Representative Steve
Pearson speak against the
amendment
thank you Mr Speaker I
Rise this
afternoon to speak against the
amendment andh House Bill
559 what this what this amendment does
it's a rewrite right so we're going to
be looking at this amendment
versus the bill itself this legislation
creates a third pension
system
this concept does not promote people
having careers with the state but simp
simply turns them into a job this will
lead to higher turnover rates has as has
happened in the state of
Alaska leading to constant and expensive
costs to train new
people doing the work of the state is
not a job hopping
opportunity under this provision an
employee who leaves State
Employment can choose to leave their
money in the plan so the system will
have to manage a plan for someone who
does not even work for the state anymore
this can be an employee who only worked
for the state for one
year the New Hampshire retirement system
stated they don't want to manage this
the original fiscal
note on this bill did not even calculate
the operational
costs associated with this type of
plan and opens up its management
potentially to a third
party nor did it calculate how many
employees we would have to
hire this
amendment has no fiscal note attached to
it or
analysis the original bill
had a $53 million impact beginning in
2026 and that is the cheapest year
annually moving forward this amendment
which makes
changes does not have a fiscal analysis
as to what those changes will do the the
the member will suspend it's getting
awful noisy in here the member has a
right to be heard if you need to have a
conversation take it out into the Annie
room remember I'm making continue thank
you Mr Speaker what this amendment will
do is it will require
employers I.E the state I.E the
taxpayer to pay into group three and
group one for the same
[Music]
employee
so the taxpayer has to pay into two
different pension systems for one
person this is because this provision
does not low
the pension debt that we are currently
working
through the Bill's methodology the
original Bill's methodology says the
costs will continue to increase
accordingly as more new hires are
eligible for the
plan now New Hampshire is not Paving the
road on this
concept we can thank the state of Alaska
for this this was implemented in Alaska
in
2006 and it has been an absolute
disaster for
Alaska so much so that half of the
members of Alaska's Senate have
announced their support for legislation
that would reinstate their pension
system unlike New Hampshire where bills
have a a single Prime sponsor Alaska
allows three prime sponsors all three of
those are
Republicans
so I rise today in
opposition to the creation of a third
pension
system that does not reduce the current
debt that we are working towards and
successfully working towards
eliminating I rise in opposition to
this because the agency that handles our
pension system doesn't want to deal with
it
and I rise in opposition to this because
this is the beginning of a road that we
cannot afford to go
down I appreciate your time thank you Mr
Speaker J recognize your representative
Simon thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr Speaker
this uh conversation is on the amendment
to the bill and with uh due respect to
my colleague and my friend um I think
he's confused as to the content of the
amendment as opposed to the content of
the original Bill uh this amendment uh
actually addresses a few of his concerns
first um if you look at if you're so
inclined page 88 of this calendar
looking at the first line the amendment
pulls uh group one uh group three this
new group um out of the New Hampshire
retirement system and puts it under the
offices of the administrator of the plan
for the Deferred Compensation Plan um
with the assist assistance of the
services of the administrative Services
um so it's no longer in the New
Hampshire retirement system if this
passes it's now moved over to this other
group and the administrator has told us
that uh he has no problem facilitating
this it's not a big deal whatsoever the
other thing that this amendment does is
it just raises the um percent of
earnable compensation uh that the
employer is going to be given towards
the employee it makes it a bit of a a
richer deal for the employee um to make
it a little bit more
ractive um as as a plan um as far as
making deposits into two separate plans
well yes because we still have the
unfunded liability the money that would
always be going towards the undefined uh
un thank you um we'll still go to that
to pay down the liability and the actual
um money that the employee and the
employer are putting and will go into
the new uh group three retirement plan
in order to ACU accumulate that
um benefit for them in the future so
we're not neglecting the um acur
liability that still has to be paid down
they're still paying towards that even
with this new group three and finally
the last thing that I would address that
my colleague said um is that this would
hurt retention uh the whole reason for
bringing it Forward uh is because
retention in with this particular group
of employees is already non-existent um
almost like a vast majority of them
don't reach vestment which means that
they'll pay into the present pension
system and they'll never see a benefit
for it so at least with this plan um
from day one their contributions the
employer contributions go to the
employee so from day one they have
access to those um so they're already
treating it like a job and not as a
career um that's half of the reason why
the bill was brought forward so just
wanted to kind of address some of um his
concerns and maybe your concerns and say
uh whether or not you plan on voting for
the overall bill this amendment
certainly makes the bill more attractive
than better thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is
amendment
246 are
you a division has been requested
members take your
seats
I'm going to wait till a few more get in
the
room representative Osborne has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded
got stand up you got to stand up and be
in your
seats it is sufficiently
seconded
CLE
members will be in their
seats the motion before us is on the
amendment
246 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you're press the
green
button chair recognizes representative
Carol Maguire for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the current retirement system is
not satisfactory to the group one state
employees since a very large percentage
of them do not serve long enough to get
any benefit from it
and if I know that this is
more comparable to Retirement Systems in
the private sector to which the group
one state employees frequently go to or
come back
from and if I know that this amendment
fixed the administrative issues that had
been pointed out at the public hearing
and there were some this is a much
cheaper plan to
administer and if I know that this
offers options to our employees that
many of them will desire would I not
press the green button and adopt this
amendment thank
you the motion before us is amendment
2406 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you will press the green button
if you're opposed you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
repres
represent all members president had an
opportunity to vote house attend to
state of the
vote 181 voting aay 192 voting aay the
amendment
fails chair recogniz the representative
Pearson thank you Mr Speaker I move inde
definite
postponement Representative Steven
Pearson moves in definite
postponement are you ready for the
question division a division has been
requested members take your
States a ro representative turot moves a
roll call as that say it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call
vote
C
the motion before us in depth
postponement on House Bill 559 this is a
roll call vote house will be in
order chair recognized Representative
Steven Pearson for with a par for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this legislation does not
reduce the current pension debt by one
penny and and if I know that adding a
third pension system to a system that we
have right now that has a plan to be
repaired and is
successful is not a great
idea and if I know that turning State
careers into simple job hopping
opportunities is not in the best
interest of the people would I vote Yes
on indefinitely postponing thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognizes representative
Carol
Maguire
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that in every one of
the 15 years I've been in the
legislature we've had multiple bills
tweaking and advis and changing our
retirement system and if I know that we
still
have a dozen or
20 this
year then
and I also know that this indefinite
postponement simply re keeps us from
considering one possible change of the
many possible issues that we have with
the retirement
system would I not consider it
inappropriate to ban this one small
piece instead of saying we will not
consider any changes to the pension
system please vote against indefinite
postponement the motion before us is
inde dep is postponing on House Bill 559
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
qu represent
qu
B members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 2011 voting aay 174 voting aay inde
def postpone and
passes majority committee on EX
executive departments Administration to
which was referred House Bill 644 FN an
act relative to regulating Barbers
cosmetologist
ands having considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
and a recommendation the bill ought to
pass with Amendment s of Tony leas and
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Jackie Grody for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
24368 printed in house record 49 page 96
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is a to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the
question a division has been
requested
a division has been
requested members will take their
seats somebody doing a doing
no
piis the motion before us is majority
committee report of autop pass has
amended House Bill
644 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative stringam representative
wolf represent Carri
represent
re
R you have to give me thumbs
up all members present and an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote
196 voting aay 178 voting aay the
committer report is
adopted committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill 436 FN local an
act relative to group two retirement
under transition Provisions retirement
system having considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation of the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Dan
Maguire for the committee chair
recognizes representative
walner thank you Mr Speaker I make a
motion that we lay this bill on the
table the motion is to lay House Bill
436 on the
table are you ready division has been
requested
members take your
seats
clear
e
motion before us is the table House Bill
436 this is going to be a division vote
chair recognizing representative walner
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that house bill
436 as amended is the first significant
spending bill before this house this
year it will spend $50
million to pay down the
retirement fund unfunded liability and
that's only a very small part of the
unfunded
liability and if I know there are many
many more bills that will come before us
in the coming months including a group
two retirement bill which is the result
of a bipartisan commission that will
need tens of millions of dollarss and if
I know that we will have a much better
handle on our revenues and our ability
to financially support spending when we
get closer to
crossover and if I know we need to be
very careful and prioritize our spending
in the second year of the banum and that
laying House Bill 436 on the table at
this time will still allow us to take
the bill off the table before crossover
when we will have a better Financial
more better a better financial
information allowing us to make a better
informed decision would I now vote Yes
to laying this bill on the
table J I recognize representative
leechman for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know House Bill 436 is a
duplicate of house bill 50 that passed
the finance committee last year by a
vote of 25 to Zer on March
16th and I know that this bill will
lower the contribution rates that our
municipalities pay the New Hampshire
retirement
system and that's one of the reasons the
municipal assoc Association supports
this
legislation and if I know with the
passage of House Bill 436 the retirement
contribution rates that our
municipalities pay will be lower which
would actually be a tax cut to those
municipalities and finally Mr Speaker if
I know that as of today there's an
adequate Surplus the fund this bill
wouldn't I press the red button against
tabling thank
you motion before us is the table House
Bill
436 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the
vote 176 voting voting nay 198 voting
nay tbling motion
fails we still got amend am they have to
take up the
amendment this brings us back to the
amendment 2458 H printed in house record
49 page 73
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the the eyes have it
the amendment is
adopted motion before us now is a to
pass with
Amendment
de are you you
ready are you ready for the question the
motion before us is ought to pass as
amended and house B
436 all in favor say I I those oppose
nay no the eyes have it and the
committee report is adopted
representative Heather Raymond declared
a conflict of interest and did not
participate
committee on finance to which was
referred House Bill 468 FNA act making
an appropriation to the Department of
Education for an attorney to rec codify
election education laws consider the
same report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment sen Tracy
emrich for the committee the amendment
is
22948 printed in house record 49 page 76
you ready ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is ought to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the I
have it and the committee report is
adopted
majority committee on finance to which
was referred House Bill 546 FN local an
act relative to the school building aid
program having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that as inexpedient
to legislate represent Tracy Emich for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee have
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass chair recognizes representative
Harkin
[Music]
Phillips so happy New Year
everybody I'm about to talk about some
big dollar figures so stay with me um
it's going to get
interesting Mr Speaker I rise today in
opposition to the motion of itl of HB
546 this is relative to school building
and the reason why I oppose it is
because our public buildings are
deteriorating at a faster Pace than we
can manage possibly to restore them or
to rebuild them on their own um at a
district level New Hampshire school
districts need our help and providing
this necessary and critical piece of
public education funding uh the member
will
suspend it's getting awful noisy in here
again we're moving along pretty good if
you need to have a conversation please
take it out into the anti room M may
continue yes New Hampshire schools
school districts need our help in
providing this necessary and critical
piece of public education funding and
it's our job as legislators to find a
way to meet that
need here are the raw facts from our own
Department of Education and even our
colleague who chairs the education
committee there's about 450 public
education buildings in our state that
serve about 165,000 students who are in
grades K through
12 about half of 450 of those buildings
are over 60 years
old these buildings frankly are old and
crumbling and the matters only get the
facts only get worse that's just a
snapshot the problem is these Antiquated
buildings are riddled with safety
concerns for for instance they're non
ADA Compliant there's a lot of imminent
danger type risks fire hazard asbest uh
lead other hazards like that there's
poor air quality water quality concerns
there's inefficient Heating and Lighting
systems there's sinking foundations
structural Integrity issues and of
course there are subpar emergency exits
which are really troubling other
buildings were built for elementary
school style students but they're
serving in a appropriately High School
bodies and frankly they're
overcrowded some of these buildings have
do not have the capability to facilitate
required stem curriculum because they
have outdated unsafe or just a complete
lack of lab
spaces but I want you to understand
these are not aesthetic issues these are
down to the stud's bone of the building
issues and the Doe's informal estimate
of New Hampshire's total need need for
school building Grant eligible funding
if there was no $50 million arbitrary
cap for the entire 450 buildings that
would exceed $120 million per fiscal
year to keep up colleagues our $50
million a year cap is not getting close
to covering the problem we're talking
about more than $70 million that go un
addressed each fiscal
year so what we know is that our current
funding is not even coming close and of
the 17 school districts that applied for
the 2425 budget cycle of school building
Aid only three school districts were
approved for that building Aid funding
leaving the last 14 in alert with
absolutely no ability um to receive help
from the state so why are so many of
those projects not being funded and this
is really the critical issue that's why
the finance committee is taking a look
not withstanding the bottleneck from the
projects during the 10-year moratorium
starting in 2009 where no building Aid
was
funded New Hampshire is paying off its
debt service to these projects and
obligated payments so this is what we
call the tail and you'll see that in the
calendar to give you an idea of the size
of this tail in
2024 it's $27.4 million and remember we
have a $50 million cap so we're talking
about even less than half goes to new
projects we're really just paying on the
old the old matter at
hand so the fact is each year the
applicant list for the school funding
building Aid gets longer and longer and
longer and while three buildings come
off six more can apply and add to the
list guys this is a compounding problem
and a stu Observer of this issue would
call it really a crisis
this bill
546 it attempts to move us in the right
direction of addressing this crisis in
two parts
one to have a non-aps continual
appropriation of a minimum of $50
million per year transferred to the
public education building fund in
addition to working on that Debt
Service what we're saying is that we
understand the obligation of playing
both off our previous commitments and
working on that service but also
spending a reasonable amount of money to
tackle the real issue at hand with you
know addressing the new projects that
are desperately needed across the state
so let's break down why you know critics
of this bill think it's a bad idea so
critics are saying it incentivizes
overspending this may be an important
theoretical argument to have in your
mind but it's just Falls flat it's not
true no district is spending more money
than they can afford on building Aid and
that's simply because we know there's a
budget process communities are informed
that they're going to have to take out
loans in addition to building aid funds
to support their Community spending on
these projects if they can't foot the
bill themselves furthermore their school
budgets are analyzing the needs of their
school systems proposing reasonable
prudent budgets that will address those
needs and then of course informing their
constituents that in order to pass that
project they're also going to attempt to
apply for this building Aid fund from
the state but we might have to go It
Alone voters know this when they vote
and if they approve those budgets they
can afford it if they don't approve
those budgets it's obviously not
affordable and you're back to the
drawing board critics will also
say why add more funding to this project
you know building Aid
Source uh funding source outside the
budget process and I'll say look we did
attempt to reach um both the governor's
proposal and this body's proposal
attempted to increase the annual funding
but the body on the other side of this
wall did not agree with that and reduced
it back to the $50 million cap per year
what we know is it's time to tell our
friends on the other side of the wall
that we actually mean that we mean it we
want to actually tackle this issue and
we'll vote to send it back to them
critics are also going to say this is
way too
expensive um we just cannot afford a
maximum of $27 million in addition to
what we're already spending per
year look it's true that many
communities can't afford it and those
districts have already been taxed to the
hillt and their property taxes can't
afford additional expenditures and
raises but we know that State's in a
better position to act our education
trust fund is at an all-time Revenue
Surplus thanks to prudent um spending
and
planning the education trust fund is
currently the source for building Aid
and it's at an excess of 160 million as
we stand right now that money is
obviously restricted for Educational
Funding purposes only and it can't be
used in other ways so it's These funds
are not going anywhere but neither is
this problem and I really it's our up to
us to
um to make this decision to use these
funds in a real positive way
critics will also ask what about the
communities that previously used these
fund or chose not to use these fund and
moved forward with their own plan you
know what happens to them and I would
say the reality is that if we understand
buildings have a 35 to 40 year turnover
of useful life that these communities
may not need this Fund in the next 5 10
or 15 years but
eventually these communities will also
need to return to this fund and yes it
will be available for them as
well all right I'm getting span here
sorry guys critics will ask why should
New Hampshire be funding more school
building Aid if we know there are fewer
students and there's a declining
population across the state and the
answer to that is easy New Hampshire's a
highly respected Department of Education
administrator put it this way with a
metaphor just because fewer cars are
crossing over a bridge doesn't mean the
bridge has to be less safe and I agree
just because there are fewer kids moving
through the threshold of our school
doors does not mean that those school
buildings need to be less safe less
modern and less
healthy we owe it to our kids to provide
building aid for you know those exact
safe healthy and um modern
schools so if you're still looking for
three reasons to vote for this bill it's
this
one HB 546 is stakeholder approved we've
got the New Hampshire School Board
Association the New Hampshire school
board authority the New Hampshire school
funding fairness project even the
Department of Education on board saying
that it would be helpful to give a more
stable um and consistent allocation to
schools year after year so that people
know how to plan to HB 546 is proactive
legislation we know that there's been a
big Supreme Court case order that's just
come down in the dual cases of conal and
Rand where the New Hampshire general
court has been put on notice notice that
we are doing it wrong that we failed and
that we have to make a big change this
is important we have been ordered by the
Supreme Court of this state to determine
how we're going to make a significant
change for the future of Education
funding this I propose is a good first
step last HB 546 is a good and wise
legislation and this is the most
important point today these buildings
are not just temples of our educational
you know progress in our communities
they're also our Civic centers of
Engagement people are learning there but
people are gathering there and taking a
little bit of ownership of their
Community for this building and I ask
you my colleagues to please support this
investment not only into the
legislature's Constitutional obligation
to provide public education to New
Hampshire students but also an
investment into the physical
representation of our community Civic
Corp for these reasons and More Mr
Speaker I ask my colleagues to vote no
on the motion of itl on HB 546 so that
another motion may be made thank you Mr
Speaker you I recognize representative
amri thank you Mr
Speaker my colleague made my
case I'm in finance the guidance to
finance is not to spend more money the
guidance to finance is to be Fair
thoughtful and
considerate which we have been for
several years we have budgeted 50
million for the last three budget cycles
and what that $50 million is paying off
is some real bad decisions that were
made 20 years ago and current debt
service for current borrowing Now The
Debt Service does come out of the $50
million the the uh fiscal note on this
says that this bill will increase
spending by $27
million it was a pretty easy decision to
say I don't I'm not really excited about
spending an additional $27
million so that's why we support the
itl I think my colleague made a a very
good case for education for p uh funding
School Renovations but keep in mind when
I joined Finance uh about 10 years ago
there were 220,000 students in this
state today there are
155,000 students a lot of schools are
going to be abandoned in a very short
period of time and merged with other
communities we there's just not enough
students anymore to have as many schools
as we have so I ask you to support the
itl and not approve an additional $27
million thank you Mr
Speaker
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
546 the division has been requested
members take your
seats representative Weber has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
e
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexperience to
legisl House Bill 546 this is a roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative Kate Murray for a
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that we are woefully
behind in our responsibility to provide
Clean safe and modern schools for the
children of New
Hampshire and if I know that this bill
provides an excellent opportunity to
provide additional support beyond what
was provided in the original budget and
that this is both a fiscally responsible
move as well as a governmentally and
civically responsible move move and if I
know that even if this leaves several
many projects yet to be addressed this
funding provides needed help to several
additional schools perhaps your school
and will put us on a better path towards
addressing the school building issues
that we face when I now press the red
button to defeat the itl motion so that
another Motion in support of school
building Aid can come forward thank you
Mr
Speaker chair recognized representative
wer for apy commentary
Cory thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
the school building aid program was
created decades ago when burgeoning
enrollment required new buildings it was
never intended to pay for repairs and
maintenance those are
always a responsibility of the district
and if I further know that declining
enrollment has left some buildings empty
and that if the district sold them at
best price they should have plenty of
money for other construction and not
come back to us in a period of declining
enrollment big numbers is not the time
to start a building boom thank you press
the green
button the motion before us is the
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legisl on House Bill 546 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
Kella of all members present and our
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 186 voting a 189 voting nay the
committee report
fails the majority report
fails he was up first for what reason
the member rise move to
table the motion is a table House Bill
are you ready for the
question a division has been
requested who requests a roll
call it is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call
vote
[Music]
clear the motion before us is the table
House Bill
546 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your opposer press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent of all members president had
an opportunity to vote also attend to
stay to the
vote 190 voting yay 187 voting nay
tabling motion
passes
the majority of the committee on finance
to which was referred HB 601 FN local an
act relative to state participation in
the Medicaid direct certification
program for free and reduced price
School meals having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Daniel papovich Muller for the majority
of the
committee the minority of the committee
on finance to which was referred HB 601
FN local having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
report report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Mary Heath for the
minority of the
committee representative hackin Phillips
is recognized to speak against the
report thank you Mr Speaker I rise today
in opposition to the motion of itl for
HB 601 relative to State participation
in the Medicaid direct certification
program for free and reduced price
School meals first let's talk about this
what this bill would actually do 601
enables let me say that again 601
enables the Department of Education to
apply to participate in the USDA pilot
program for Medicaid direct
certification that methodology for free
and reduced price School meals covering
K through 12 kids it's this bill D
stigmatizes and simplifies the existing
process of requiring parents to fill out
paper enrollment forms and it really
tries to capture the kids who qualify
and need these meals but for some reason
don't return the
forms if the state already has data on
existing Medicaid eligible families and
kids throughout DHHS records this data
set could securely and accurately be
shared with the Department of Education
to automatically enroll those eligible
kids into the free and reduced meal
program without the existing unreliable
and inefficient step of returning that
paper paper enrollment thank you so why
is the Medicaid direct certification
process for free ose meal application
important we know that New Hampshire
kids are hungry and food insufficiency
is on the rise for our students we all
have anecdotes but we don't need to rely
on them because we have the US Census
pulse survey conducted by the experts at
the New Hampshire hunger solutions that
shows us approximately 200,000 kids in
our state live in food insecure
households the State also notes that
more kids were taking advantage of the
free and reduced meal program since the
pandemic started according to the
Department of education's own
data so if we know there's an increased
need what is pres preventing New
Hampshire from feeding these kids I have
to ask when did feeding hungry at risk
kids become such a bad thing the long
and short of it folks the answer is
money New
Hampshire there their adequacy
calculation for school funding is
significantly impact on uh is
significantly impacted on the Medicaid
direct certification because any
increase across the board on free and
reduced meal counts would result in a
corresponding increase in the adequacy
aid
calculation over the Baseline so one
estimate by the Department of Education
is that a 15% increase in the amount of
free and reduced School Meal kids would
result in approximately
wait for it $114 million increase in the
adequacy for fiscal year
2027 that's the first point at which a
fiscal impact of the direct
certification would really start to show
up here in our state another estimate by
the same body the doe provides that
projected increase of over $190 million
over the bium but to be fair the
department of education's analyst can
actually provide a
stic statistically meaningful margin of
error and it's likely that the actual
estimates fluctuate by tens of millions
of dollars so we as legislators
legislators are left guessing what is
the actual amount of such a program what
is that impact even if we know it's
significant so I'm asking you to open
your hearts and Minds EX look to the
possibility of accepting this policy and
the way we do that is by dispelling some
of the critiques
the estimate of the Department of
Education that it could be up to $190
million over the bium and this idea that
it's too expensive and our education
trust fund can't um possibly support it
well we know according to the Department
of Education that in their own analysis
the estimates provided are unreliable
because first the adequacy formula
relies heavily on inflated free and
reduced meal program numbers since um
that pandemic era waiver was in effect
we also know that it's unreliable
because Property Data also fluctuates
vastly year
toe so it's important to acknowledge
that the change to direct certification
will cause a significant impact on to
our budget but that significant impact
is already approaching us on the
horizon don't forget that the education
trust fund is strong it's currently at
$160 million with the largest revenue
collection months of March and April
coming just around the corner the state
is an all-time Revenue Surplus and we
should not be afraid to use it remember
that the education trust fund is
restricted to be utilized for
educational expenditures
only and that this cause is a worthy
cause what better than feeding our
neediest kids at school when our coffers
are
overflowing there's also a critique that
we've already changed our Ed education
adequacy formula in the last budget
cycle so so why would we do it again
look it's true that we did make a
significant increase to education
spending during the bipartison
negotiations of our last budget cycle
and it to be fair it's a historic and
commendable bipartisan effort from this
chamber and the one behind
us
but it doesn't affect this budget as
much and we should remember that this
decision to change wouldn't affect us in
a fiscal impact for many years to come
the other reality is that we've already
been ordered by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court to make a significant
change in the way we provide a
constitutionally adequate public
education a bigger and more radical
change has been ordered by our court and
we as legislators have the important
task of meeting this challenge here this
bill is our chance for us to make
another historic and commendable
change there's considerable concerns
about privacy rights that we keep
hearing about many people are saying
they're concerned about different state
agencies sharing information um without
consent and I think it's best to leave
the other B's testimony um as an example
of why this is not a significant
concern during the other B's hearings on
the matter a simple fix was proposed to
avoid privacy concerns that have been
raised by allowing the Medicaid
applicant to authorize sharing of data
with the Department of Education at the
time of
application similarly allowing the
Department of Education to take to make
a free and reduced meal application this
applicant the parent presumably could
authorize the Department of Education to
verify its Medicaid enrollment with the
Department of Health and Human Services
simply by checking a box on the
application form we are further assured
that the few staff at DHHS and the
Department of Education would actually
have access to this limited student or
parental information because this
program was a computer-based data match
program we even know that fewer staff at
our local schools would have access to
this information as
well
so while we have an example from our
past that even gives us greater
Assurance we know that privacy concerns
have not been raised in the 16 years
that the New Hampshire um state
government has been directly certifying
children based on snap and tanif program
and that the state is confident that
they'll be able to maintain these
constitutional parameters of privacy for
Medicaid direct certification as
well all right last Point parental
rights we hear about this all the time
parents don't want their children
enrolled for a program that they haven't
consented to and the easy fix that we
just talked about that the other body
proposed is one way that the Medicaid
applicant process ensures parents are
given ample notice to consent the
participation in the fnr program
additional efforts at PR providing
parent notice can be made including an
opt out and that exists in this
legislation as always parents are given
the tools to be informed about the
program and are in control of their
children's participation in it but let's
not throw out the possibility of an
efficient fnr enrollment program through
Medicaid direct certification because of
this Loosely based
argument guys in conclusion many of us
believe that feeding hungry kids at
school is a natural progression of our
legislation here in the state if not
today many believe it will eventually
become the law so now is the time to
allow New Hampshire to spend a little
more on her most needy kids because
we've been ordered by a court in part to
do so and because we're benefiting from
this historic Revenue Surplus that make
this endeavor possible this enabling
legislation is not only feasible it's
also morally imperative to Pro
prioritize childhood hunger in a rich
developed Society New Hampshire children
are a collective future and everyone
benefits when they're fed and healthy
because they make better informed
citizens and so Mr Speaker for these
reasons I urge you to vote no on the
motion of itl against HB 601 and thank
you Mr Speaker I request a roll call
vote representative papovich meller is
recognized to speak for the
report
sorry thank you Mr Speaker and uh
distinguished colleagues I will be as
brief as possible the fact that HB 601
is not about addressing hunger in public
schools is easily shown by its price tag
190 million over a bium to be to benefit
about 7,700 children that's over 25k per
kid per banum or $68 per kid per day
unless our schools School cafeterias
have Micheline stars that kind of money
ain't paying for food so do we have a
hunger problem in New
Hampshire yes even though one could
argue with a definition of food
insufficiency that combines people who
are genuinely not having enough food
with people who have enough food but
don't have exactly the food they like
based on the definition my family is
food insufficient and trust me we are
anything
but now
the state does have hungry families what
we don't have any information on any
documentation to indicate that is
happening are kids who are not getting
food while attending public schools
which is the narrower Target of this
particular Bill an esteemed colleague
sent an email to the finance committee
members suggesting that we could learn
more by hunger about hunger by
volunteering for and 68 hours of hunger
I took that offer I volunteered and by
the way it's a great charity if you have
an hour on every Wednesday uh
evening but even that charity is
designed to address the 68 hours when
kids are not in school and that's
happening because nobody that I spoke
with there could show me one case of a
kid being denied food in a public school
the concern is what happens when they go
home and their families don't have the
resources and those are things that
would not be addressed by this bill
during the Senate house joint committee
that I was also on we asked the doe for
any information to show that kids are
not getting fed meals in public schools
no data so we asked them to at least
give us some statistics and they will
gather that on which schools are writing
off school debt for school launches you
know if people get fed but don't pay for
it that has to be written off at the end
of the year we should have some data and
hopefully that will help a little bit
with establishing whether this happens
or not even though then the kids are
still getting fed they just don't pay
for it and the taxpayers have to
pay now there are two reasons listed
generally considered valid for people
not enrolling in a program they are
eligible for in this particular one the
fact that the paperwork is a pain which
frankly it
is but the solution to that is to
simplify the paperwork and the doe
assured us that they will look into that
and they will try to create a portal to
AC to make this easier also if a person
is already eligible for Medicaid we hope
that they should be able to just prove
they're eligible for Medicaid instead of
having to prove once more that they
income
limited second parent choice a lot of
parents choose not to let kids
participate in this program whether they
do it because of the well documented
stigma of being part of this program
kids can be really really mean to each
other at various ages despite the best
attempts of teachers to show them
otherwise or for any other reasons the
parents know better what's good for
their kid than the state does we should
respect that choice and I think that
using HB 601 to have people choose
between not applying for Medicaid or
having their private data used to enroll
them in a program they do not want to be
a part of is
unconscionable
so what is the purpose of this bill well
clearly it's to add another 190 million
to education
funding problem with that is that the
budget has already been completed and in
that budget we already increased
education funding by $193 million let me
be clear the time to change State
education funding is during the budget
process not way after that with a
separate bill and as the finance to
committee clerk I know firsthand that we
already considered the fact that kids
are eligible for free and reduced meals
and they are not enrolled in it because
it does affect education funding
negatively those school districts lose
on some education funding that they
would otherwise
need and we did our best to allocate
funds to compensate for that and again
that was part of the reason why the
increase in the education budget was so
high given that we already already done
the best we could and we used all funds
that we could wisely use asking for
another 190 Millions is the very
definition of fiscally responsibility
making HB 601 impossible to justify
Frankly Speaking for myself the fact
that our current education formula adds
125,000 in education funding a year for
every kid that is in the free and clear
free and reduced meal program shows that
the education for formula is broken and
we really got to focus on fixing the
darn thing next year because this is not
justifiable one last fact during the
committee work session on this bill I
asked New Hampshire hunger Solutions who
were advocating for this bill if they
have any information on any kids being
denied food while attending Public
Schools they stated on the record that
they have no such
information if the very Organization
advocating for this bill has no data to
show that the problem we are supposed to
spend $190 million to solve even
exists how could we justify voting for
this bill please join me in supporting
the itl motion on hbx 601 thank you and
Mr Speaker I will not yield to any
question thank
you
representative hackin Phillips has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded all right then it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your
seats
oh
e
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient of
legislate this is a roll call
vote representative Kate Murray is
recognized for a parliamentary
inir
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that there
was significant support for this bill
when it originally passed out of the
house with a strong recommendation of
ought to
pass if I know the exaggerated concerns
about the funding issues have been
adequately
addressed if I know that there are
several thousands of students who would
be who would be eligible for free and
reduced lunch with this program who are
not now enrolled in the current program
for many assorted reasons and if I
believe we have a responsibil ability to
address childhood hunger what I now
press the red button to oppose this itl
in order to entertain another motion
which would allow the state to initially
apply to participate in a program that
would provide in some cases the only
breakfasts and lunches that some
children will have thank you Mr
Speaker representative wer is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
program for free and reduced meals at
schools is frequently used where the
student part includes a high percentage
of this group and they Grant further
funds none of which go for more meals
just goes just whatever they want to do
with it the Medicaid Program for
children is a separate program it's in a
separate agency these agencies don't
talk to each other the parents may have
different reasons for not for being
involved in one and not the other this
would be a
tremendous slush fund going to schools
that really has nothing scheduled for it
and as I say will be in order and
representative wer you're going to ask
me a question right even though it is
used with the the free and reduced meals
identity it does not pay for more meals
please press the green
button the question before the house is
the majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
601 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor press the green button if
you're opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
to
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote
and I
voted
the majority of the committee on finance
which was referred House Bill 620 FN an
act new title establishing a division of
early learning in the Department of
Education and relative to a pre
kindergarten pilot program having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is in expedient to legislate
representative Tracy emmer for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study representative Mary Heath for the
minority of the
committee representative Heath is
recognized speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker I rise today
in opposition to the itl motion the bill
in its current form needs further
discussion but remains a critical
priority for our state New Hampshire is
one of only six states that do not
provide funding for early learning or
some form of mixed delivery system for
our three and four-year-old children HB
620 establishes a division of early
learning and the bill requires the
director of The Early Learning to design
create and administer a three-year
highquality community-based mixed
delivery public pre kindergarten member
will suspend for a sec uh I appreciate
folks going out to have your
conversations but migrate quietly wow it
got quiet fast thank you can proceed
thank you Mr Speaker there's a high
level of interest in further developing
this program in fact HB 620 needs more
study I respectfully ask that the itl be
overturned so that a motion of interim
study can be made to continue this
important work for New Hampshire's
children please vote no on the itl
motion thank you Mr
Speaker represent representative Emer is
recognized to speak for the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker the concept of a pilot program I
think has already been taken up for pre
pre kindergarten children in
1965 the federal government set up a
program called Head Start Head Start was
for children up to age
five and
uh oh closer to the mic oh my gosh is
that better
oh now I can hear it okay do I me to
start from the beginning or are we all
set all right all right all right so we
had a program this started in
1965 and as of last year if you go to
the Head Start website it said
educationally it didn't have any value
it didn't make a bit of difference to
the the kids that were in the program
from when they started kindergarten so
educationally it was it was a bomb
however if you go to Head Starts website
today it was updated in June
2023 now this is a social program this
is not an educational program this is a
program that promotes learning of
discipline for kids and for their
parents and has social
aspects no educational
mention so I I'm thinking here we are
we're going to mimic what they did cuz
we can do it
better we can make preschool a learning
experience for educ
ation now I would add that this program
started out Head Start started out in
the uh in Economic Development it
transitioned to Health and Human
Services not the Department of Education
so looking at a a test program to
educate prek kids has already failed
let's don't repeat the pass please
support the itl
the question is on the majority
committee report of an expedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I I actually heard the division she she
had requested a roll call
oh it turns out you've requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be roll call vote sorry about
that
clear
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 620 this is a
roll call vote representative hacken
Phillips is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill will
establish a division of early learning
within the Department of Education and
authorize the director of said division
to design design create and administer a
three-year pilot program for three and
four-year-old children that is a high
quality communitybased and offers a
mixed delivery model to the benefit of
the children and families throughout the
state and if I know that there is
significant stakeholder interest in the
enactment of such an early learning
pilot program support registered by
employers concerned about Workforce and
child care shortages Educators concerned
with building a robust Early Learning
educ ation program and parents concerned
with finding high quality Early Learning
programs across the state and if I
further know that a vote of itl does not
address the unanswered fiscal and
implementation questions about this
potential program and would be closing
the door to an important educational
opportunity for New Hampshire's youngest
Learners putting us alongside a minority
of five other states that have not yet
prioritized early public learning
programs s then would I now press the
red button and vote no against the itl
motion so that a more prudent motion can
be made in support of HB 620 thank you
Mr
Speaker representative wer is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that now is not the time for creating a
new extensive school program
especially when it mirrors a decades old
program that was adjudged a
failure would I now refuse to raise
false hopes and spend wastefully and
press the green
button the question before the house is
a majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
620 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor press the green button if
you're opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
is
representative
he representative
Heath have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 188 in the affirmative 185 in the
negative the report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on finance
to which was referred Senate Bill 239 FN
an act relative to the use of harm
reduction services to treat alcohol and
other substance misuse having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative J.R
Hull for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Mary Jane
walner for the minority of the
committee representative tersi is
recognized to speak against the
committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker SP 239 FN before us today passed
this body back on May 18th on that day
we heard debate on floor Amendment 1861
which outlined clarifying details
limiting the definition of harm
reduction with a strong bipartisan vote
of
359 to 18 the amendment passed and the
bill as amended passed on a Voice vote
harm reduction is a spectrum of
strategies to tackle the complex and
multifaceted drug misuse crisis choosing
to work to minimize the harmful effects
of drug use rather than simply ignore or
condemn misuse has been shown to save
lives the policy on harm reduction
services in SB 239 is the established
house position as we all know when a
bill goes to a second committee it is
not to debate the policy or a chance to
take another bite at the Apple it was up
to house finance to review the financial
implications of s SP 239
in division 3 the objections were solely
around the policy and definitions in the
bill not funding or cost as the state
sees the number of overdoses rising to
near Peak levels a more expansive
approach to combat the opioid and
substance misuse crisis is required and
S SP 239 does just that if this bill is
signed into law one thing is clear lives
will be saved
alternatively politely killing the bill
through interim study will only delay
the good that this bill can do and will
lead to more senseless deaths I urge you
to join me in voting no on the motion of
interim study so another motion can be
made and I ask for a division vote thank
you Mr
Speaker representative Hol is recognized
to speak for the committee
report sorry what what is the member R
because I'm doing the floor speech uh I
think we turned it
in I I can't hear you I'm sorry I'm je
we have representative H signed up we're
going to do the floor Amendment for
whole I I don't know how to describe
that as a
mistake
yes all right
Ed
speak chair recognized representative
Edwards to speak for the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker
um many people would know that I've been
out of the net since July with a series
of medical issues and I have missed a
lot of the debate in division 3 but I
have not um let go of this bill since it
came to division 3 uh some things that
became very obvious that I I believe is
represented in the committee
recommendation is that this bill
requires further study and let me give
you some examples the prime sponsor of
the House of the of the of the of this
bill um ended up uh coming and working
with us as well as some representatives
from HHS and and the division three and
uh a couple of things that we
identified uh after that in
conversations that I could attend
because I was down uh was that uh the
definition of harm reduction is really
Broad and flexible and it's and it's so
vague that the things that it could do
are unbounded now the definition of harm
reduction
got added to this bill that we did vote
on in the house and pasted by a
physician who has worked years in this
area um and so he added the harm
reduction definition knowing that it was
needed well it was necessary but not
sufficient because one of the issues
that are being had around the nation as
harm reduction is is is used as a shield
to prevent Common Sense from interfering
ing um they are implementing things like
safe needle exchanges uh safe injection
sites uh New York City installed vending
machines that offered free crack pipes
um uh in uh in one of the West Coast
cities whether it was Seattle or
Portland it slips my mind uh they had an
initiative called harm reduction where
they thought it would reduce the harm to
individuals if the government provided
them with a
house all right so so the boundaries on
this are just unlimited uh in in I think
it was in Seattle the uh businesses said
the problem with people uh congregating
on our streets is so massive it's
driving around it's driving off Street
traffic and you're killing our
businesses so the city of Seattle
relented after 2 three years and started
to move the the um the vagrance off of
the business Corridor somewhere else and
the harm reduction Coalition of that
area came out and sued them because they
said if you force a movement of a
homeless person that is by definition
doing more harm and u a member will
suspend for a minute so this this been
to the policy committee and now it's in
finance yes I'm to it okay but okay so
this is a this is an often confused
point I think that one of the
obligations of Finance is to take a look
to see if we're doing a program that's
sustainable and supportable over the
long term and that certainly includes
fiscal accountability and responsibility
and I've just described how this
particular definition of harm reduction
can be so abused that it's no longer a
FIS Ally responsible thing we've sort of
all reached this level of consensus that
safe needle exchanges make sense but we
haven't debated all the other things so
what uh what we've agreed to do is to
take this bill uh and one of the members
of the other house that had been a key
sponsor of the harm reduction bill is
introducing uh a late Bill to the Senate
to the other people um saying that
uh we want to create a counterveiling
weight so that it isn't just looking at
harm reduction in the in the micro
sphere this is called systems um systems
uh um subsystem optimization where you
can optimize a subsystem and do harm to
the overall system so what we wanted to
do
representative we got to get to the
fiscal bit of this I I'm really having a
hard
we have to get to the fiscal part of
this okay I think we have but I I will
defer to your judgment on that I I
disagree with it but I I I'll do what
you're saying um all right so other than
the sustainability thing what has been
highlighted in uh this effort is that
the money that's going to start getting
spent for harm harm reduction uh is is
going to be done by things like the
opioid abatement committee and by the
governor's Commission on alcohol and
drug abuse neither of which are
legislative bodies and so the decisions
that they might make are not subject to
the review of the legislature what
happens is they put together a program
and in that program they spend money and
then they go to the uh executive counsel
and the executive counsel approves each
program nobody reviews the budget they
review the whether or not to approve the
contract and so if you are like me and
you think that the power of the purse is
an essential power of the legislature
you would recognize that the way this
has been set up is is is a bit
unconstitutional and um Patrick tus of
the governor's commission agrees that we
ought to take a look at what it would
what we would do to make sure that there
is some legislative oversight and
approval in the in the budget process
which I think is extremely reasonable if
you believe in the Constitution so for
those two reasons um interim study is
appropriate and we're going to have our
opportunity because the senator has
promised to bring forth a bill in the
Senate that would identify uh these two
issues for further discussion and um and
so I I ask you to support the committee
recommendation on on interim study
because this bill does need interim
study it does need interim study and
it's not like any of us want it to go
away it's just that we want to have it
sustainable and constitutional and
subject to sort of public scrutiny and
not not just u a horse run wild so I'm
going to ask you to support the
committee
report there has been a request for a
division vote this will be a division
vote members please take your
seats
represent
the questions on the majority committee
report of interim study and this is a
division
vote representative Stringham is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that Senate Bill 239
adds harm reduction services to the
scope of the governor's Commission on
Alcohol and Other Drug prevention
treatment and Recovery a needed addition
to the program and if I know that this
life-saving bill passed this body on a
Voice vote after a diligent effort led
to the passage of a floor Amendment with
359 bipartisan votes when concerns about
the definition of harm reduction
Services were addressed by a physician
uh and colleagues with years of
experience in the
field and if I know that after passing
this bill it went to finance for a
review of the budgetary impacts and if I
know that there are no costs with this
bill and the only concerns are policy
that were thoroughly discussed before
being passed would I then press the red
button so that another motion can be
made thank
you representative Wier is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the primary task of a legislature
is to set clear and well-defined limits
to any proposal
and I know if lacking that language the
bill becomes ineffective subject to
constant
litigation additions from who knows who
maybe some other
agency so what I now press the green
button so this can go to interim study
where we can narrow this definition down
while we see dozens of other states that
all have different ones let's have one
narrow down for New Hampshire that can't
be misinterpreted please press the green
button the questions on the majority
committee report of interim study this
is a division vote if you're in favor
press the green button opposed press the
red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
for
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend of the state
of the
vote 186 in the affirmative 185 in the
negative the report is adopted and I
voted to break the
CH the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne for the
third reading
motion resolve that the has now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered a third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
a day it be to meet tomorrow Thursday
January 4th at 9:00
a.m. the questions on a third reading
motion all those in
favor all those opposed the eyes have it
and the motion is adopted
all
right tell everybody to calm down we
have consents and announcements the
house will be an order we have
announcements and unanimous
consent representative Hobson is
recognized for an announcement and let's
make sure we can hear
her the house will be in order
thank you everybody sorry to slow you
down but I want to tell you about a
bipartisan event that's going to be
happening on Wednesday January 17th at
300 p.m. join the American Hotel and
lodging uh with the New Hampshire
lodging and Restaurant Association we're
going to teach you how to save lives the
hotel industry can work to identify the
common signs of human trafficking and
how to respond when an employee has a
suspicion that human trafficking is
happening in the hotel it'll be at the
holiday in capital room on uh Main North
Main Street in conquered so join us at 3
p.m. and I'm going to have Flyers
tomorrow morning in the anti room thank
you there are more and it is a short
walk to the door maybe we could start
talking once we get
there
representative veral is recognized for
unanimous consent relative to education
in
Deerfield thank you Mr Speaker it's the
feel-good story of the year for for
myself and a lot of my
constituents so Deerfield has sent all
of our high school students uh to
conquered high school for the last 20
years
and that was an original 10-year
contract and then 10 years ago we reup
for another 10 years and there was some
discontent about the the second
extension people wanted expanded school
choice and so for 10 years this has been
percolating in Deerfield last year we
were presented an unprecedented 133-year
contract with conquer which is a fine
school right down the road I have I have
all all the respect for conquered high
school for sure but it was clear that
Deerfield families wanted choice and
they voted that contract
down and our school board listened we we
elected a new majority and they listened
to the voters and now instead of sending
all of our kids to one public school we
now have the choice of three Public
Schools three public schools and what's
interesting about that is more than half
of our current eighth graders have
chosen one of the other schools
and and I don't mean one out of the two
other Schools they're all going to to
one and and so it one size fits all is
an impossibility right and and for
someone like me it's not perfect I'm a
universal school choice guy but we
expanded options to other public schools
and it's helped families interesting
side effect people want to tell us right
the school choice makes kids flee the
public school system if we have a
expanded school choice the the the kids
run away our high school population
Public School High School population has
increased this year
unexpectedly because families are
choosing to put their children back into
the public school system because there
were more options and I tell you this
because we hear about pop School
populations Public School populations
declining and if your district has
declining student
populations look to Deerfield as a a
potential ray of light that if you allow
children from other districts to choose
to come to your local public schools you
might find your enrollment goes
up I am glad to see Deerfield kids
willingly happily reentering the public
school system because they now have the
option at least one option one choice
that they want so it's a it's a great
success for the families the parents and
certainly the students a
Deerfield I want you all to think
outside the box as you struggle with
your local public education we can have
unexpected outcomes that are actually
very positive for students and families
and I just wanted to share the good news
uh that Deerfield recently celebrated I
I thank you for staying late I thank you
for your time and and uh have a safe
journey home tonight thank
[Applause]
you representative oler is recognized
for unanimous consent relative to
taxation have we heard enough about
taxation tonight thank you Mr
Speaker as previously stated it is the
duty of residents of New Hampshire to
pay taxes indeed it is constit Duty it's
been there since 1784 it clearly states
without any question without any
hesitation that it is a duty to support
the operations of the state with taxes
and if necessary personal service
however those are for a limited purpose
that's the enjoyment of life liberty and
property our constitution says nothing
about providing for the livelihood of
others for providing business Enterprise
be kept afloat or for taking the
property without due proc
process for any
purpose not mentioned in the previous
speech however were two little Clauses
that we have the right to ask and demand
of our Representatives what taxes are
being paid and when and
secondly that the only laws which the
citizens of New Hampshire responsible to
are those that are made by themselves or
their
Representatives administrative fees are
not laws and should not be used as a
form of
Taxation so Mr Speaker to comply with
our
Constitution and in remembrance of the
recent anniversary of the tea
party and recalling the words of French
philosopher aasat taxation is legal
plunder unless it's used for purposes in
the modern jargon taxation is
[Applause]
theft representative Wier is recognized
for unanimous consent relative to fiscal
issues thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you for those of you that had the
courtesy to
remain last year when you said sent us a
bill that passed this house and it had a
fiscal note you sent it to finance
committee we put it in the
budget and 25 of those bills we just
disposed of in the consent calendar
because they were included in the budget
we retained them to make sure they were
even though it went to the other
side but what's happened since we passed
a budget that is effective until J June
of
so now if you have a bill that has a
fiscal note we don't have a budget to
put it in we may not have the money to
fund it so what I'm asking when you have
a bill in your committee that has a
fiscal
note talk talk it over with the
Department that's
affected you want to add three new
people to do something is there three
people you can get rid of before you
start coming asking for more people or
if you have some excess funds for what
ever reason that you want to pay
something for some other
function put it in that put it in that
budget that that you have the fiscal
note on that you're going to transfer
money from here to there and when you
get to the finance committee yes we love
it we'll pass it so please help us out
look at all those committees with look
at all those bills with fiscal notes and
discuss it with the Department where do
you think you can get the money from
before you come and ask us if it's a
million bucks Maybe maybe we have it but
don't forget we put $100 million in the
sonunu youth litigation fund and some of
the latest visits to fiscal that's not
enough and they'll be coming back with
priorities so help us out fiscal notes
try to find it within the bill and
within your department I thank you very
much for your
[Applause]
attention
representative Osborne moves at the
house stand on recess for the purpose of
the introduction of bills and rooll Bill
amendments and rooll Bill reports vacate
motions and receiving messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppos nay the
eyes have it and the motion is adopted
the house is in recess until Thursday
January 4th 2024 at 9
a.m.